Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, everybody. Now, Theo, our producer, has asked me to point out to you that this episode is very, very gory. So if you're listening in the car with small children, consider yourselves warned. Enjoy. Dead? Is it possible? He the bold rider, Custer our hero, the first in the fight, Charming the bullets of yore to fly wider, Far from our battle kings, ringlets of light.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先收听，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好。我们的制作人西奥让我提醒大家，本集内容非常非常血腥。所以如果你正和小孩在车里听，请自行做好心理准备。收听愉快。死了？这可能吗？他，无畏的骑手，卡斯特我们的英雄，冲锋在前的第一人，曾迷得过去的子弹飞得更远，远离我们的战王，光明的卷发。
Dead, our young chieftain, and dead, all forsaken, No one to tell us the way of his fall. Slain in the desert, and never to waken. Never, not even to victory's call. Backward, again and again they were driven, shrinking to close with the lost little band. Never a cap that had worn the bright seven bowed till its wearer was dead on the strand. Closer and closer, the death circle growing. Ever the leader's voice, clary and clear,
死了，我们年轻的酋长，所有人都在叹息，没有人能告诉我们他陨落的方式。在荒漠中战死，永远不会醒来。永远不会，哪怕是胜利的号角。一次又一次，他们被逼得节节后退，蜷缩着不敢靠近那支孤立无援的小部队。没有一顶戴着那七颗耀眼星徽的军帽肯低下头，直到它的主人战死在岸边。越来越近，死亡的包围圈在缩小。领队的声音始终高亢而清晰，
rang out his words of encouragement glowing. We can but die once, boys. We'll sell our lives, dear. Stirring words, Dominic. Up there with McGonagall. Yeah. In the annals of the rest is history poetry that's actually much better than mcgonigal that is much better it's very rousing it's like the sort of
回响着他那激昂的鼓励。我们只能死一次，伙计们。我们要让我们的生命死得有价值。这话说得真动听，多米尼克。简直能跟麦戈纳加尔（McGonagall）媲美了。是啊。在《历史的余烬》诗歌史上，这其实比麦戈纳加尔写得好得多，真的好得多。非常振奋人心，有点像亨利·纽博特（Henry Newbolt）爵士的风格之类的。是的，确实如此，而且它的作者后来也成了节目的朋友——弗雷德里克·惠特克（Frederick Whittaker），对吧？他写了那部两卷本的卡斯特传记，就在卡斯特阵亡短短几周后。没错。这一切都非常激动人心，不是吗？它勾勒出了一种形象……卡斯特的最后一战。那位卷发的美少年英雄。哦。当然，在小大角战役时，他其实并没有卷发。
sir henry newbolt or something yeah it is and it was written by a man who's first becoming a friend of the show frederick whittaker right who uh wrote the two volume biography of custer yeah within barely weeks of him being killed. Yes. And it's all very stirring, isn't it? And it kind of creates this image of... Custer's last stand. The ringleted young hero. Oh. Of course, he didn't have ringlets at the Battle of the Little Bighorn.
死了，我们年轻的酋长。对啊。我的意思是，他这时候还是个年轻的酋长吗？他正在脱发。但这首诗赋予了“最后一战”这个神话以声音，即卡斯特的最后一战。是的，温泉关，平原上的温泉关。而这正是今天这集的主题——卡斯特的最后一战，美国乃至世界历史上史诗般的时刻之一。
Dead our young chieftain. Yeah. I mean, is he a young chieftain at this point? He's losing his hair. But this is the poem giving voice to the myth of the last stand, Custer's last stand. Yeah, the Thermopylae, the Thermopylae of the plains. And that is the subject of today's episode, Custer's last stand, one of the epic moments in American and world history.
但当时究竟发生了什么？听这个节目的每个人肯定都听过这个系列之前的 67 集吧。所以你们应该记得，在 1876 年 6 月 25 日，卡斯特找到了他一直在寻找的苏族、拉克塔苏族和夏延人的营地，那是一个巨大的帐篷村。他分兵了。他派老冤家本廷（Benteen）队长率部向左侧迂回。
But what actually happened? Surely anybody listening to this will have listened to the previous 67 episodes in this series. So you will remember on the 25th of June, 1876, Custer has found the Sioux, Lakota Sioux and Cheyenne encampments that he was looking for, enormous village of teepees. He'd divided his forces. He'd sent Captain Benteen, his old enemy, off way to the left in a kind of sweeping move.
他派雷诺（Reno）少校顺着河边进攻，而雷诺表现得简直名誉扫地。正如我们的制作人西奥所指出的，汤姆，你把雷诺模仿得活像《史酷比》里的夏奇（Shaggy），非常感人。总之，那是一场极其血腥混乱的撤退，他们最后困在了一座山头上。现在，卡斯特一直在
He had sent Major Reno down by the river, and Reno had absolutely disgraced himself. As Theo, our producer, pointed out, you did a great impersonation of Reno as Shaggy from Scooby-Doo, Tom, which was very moving. So, incredibly bloody and chaotic retreat, and they end up on a hill. Now, Custer has been up on the bluffs
河东岸的山崖上俯瞰着下方的战局。大约在 3 点 30 分，我们最后一次见到他的身影时，他派出一个信使——小号手乔瓦尼·马蒂尼（Giovanni Martini），去把本廷队长找来：“本廷，快来，有个大村庄，把弹药包带上。”这当然就是他留下的那条传世遗言——好吧，我们来宣读一下这条讯息，因为细节很重要我认为：“本廷，快来，大村庄，快点，带弹药包。W·W·库克。”所以这位库克是个留着大得难以置信的羊排胡、侧须的人，带弹药包。这些就是指令。现在，这很有争议，不是吗？接下来会发生什么呢？因为本廷确实收到了这条消息，很多人因为后来发生的事而对他的行为提出了严厉的批评。
on the eastern side of the river he's been looking down at the scene and at about 3 30 the last glimpse we have of him he has sent a message uh he sent a trumpeter giovanni martini to fetch captain bentin bentin come quickly there's a big village bring the ammunition packs and that is of course the message that's gone down as his last well just to read the message because it's the details are important i think bentin come on big village be quick bring packs ww cook so this is cook is a guy with unbelievably huge mutton chops, side whiskers, bring packs. So these are the instructions. Now it's controversial, isn't it? What then happens because Bentin does get this message and a lot of people are very critical of him because of what
但需要指出的是，这些指令是相互矛盾的。因为一方面，卡斯特在说“快来”。但另一方面，他又说“去拿弹药”。而弹药在小溪很远的上游，因为骡子的行军速度要慢得多。所以本廷收到消息后，他必须决定：好吧，我该优先考虑什么？我是优先考虑策马去和卡斯特会合，还是优先考虑先去拿弹药？所以你可以理解为什么他（你知道的）可能会感到困惑。而且他还在生闷气，不是吗？他很不高兴那天早些时候自己被派到左边那么远的地方去。他认为卡斯特派他去那里是为了把他从前线（你知道的）支开，让他捞不到任何功劳。
happens. But just to point out, those instructions are contradictory. Because on the one hand, Custer is saying, come quick. But on the other hand, he's saying, go and get the ammunition. And the ammunition is quite a long way up the creek, because the mules are much slower. So when Bentin gets it, he's got to decide, well, what do I prioritise? Do I prioritise galloping off to to join custer or do i prioritize getting the ammunition first so you can see why he you know he might be in a muddle he's also sulking isn't he he wasn't happy that he'd been sent off way to the left earlier that day that morning uh he thinks that custer has sent him there to get him out of the you know to the
所有的功劳都会被卡斯特一个人抢走。所以本廷当时只是带着手下慢条斯理地溜达。事实上，他们见到的第一个人是卡纳佩（Canapé）中士——我们上节课提到过他——他被派去拿弹药，以便跟上辎重队。中士骑马路过时说的话，给人的印象好像是战斗已经胜利了，不是吗？
front line he's not going to get any glory. Custer will get all the glory himself. So Benteen has just been sort of pottering about with his men in this desultory way. And actually the first person they see is Sergeant Canapé, who we talked about last time, who's been sent to get the ammunition to go to the pack sort of train. And the sergeant says, as he rides past, he gives the impression that the battle is won already, doesn't he?
“我们抓住他们了，伙计们。我们把他们打得落花流水，”他说。现在，我猜这是因为卡纳佩最后看到的是雷诺的冲锋，或者是雷诺的手下在开枪。他以为一切都进行得极其顺利。一切都进展得非常顺利。是的。本廷一行人继续前进。他们其实是以快步走的速度前进，而不是策马奔腾什么的。当他们接近河流时，他们看到了小号手约翰·马丁（John Martin），也就是乔瓦尼·马蒂尼。这个英语说得不太好的小号手把那张潦草的字条交给了他。
We've got them, boys. They're licking the stuffing out of them, he says. Now, I'm guessing this is because the last that Canapé saw was Reno's charge, possibly Reno's men firing. And he thinks all is going swimmingly. It's all going very well. Yeah. Benteen and co. continue. They're really moving at a fast walk, not a gallop or anything like that. As they approach the river, they see the trumpeter, John Martin, Giovanni Martini. And the trumpeter, who doesn't speak very good English, gives him the scrawled message.
他用生硬的英语说：“印第安人逃跑了。印第安人正在逃跑。”所以本廷心想——他其实对此很不高兴。他心想：“噢，我错失良机了。卡斯特终究还是要抢走所有的功劳。真是个烂摊子。真是耻辱。”现在，有些作家在这里对本廷提出了非常严厉的批评。T·J·斯蒂尔斯（T.J. Stiles）说，这是一道明确无误的积极命令，要求与卡斯特会合，并强烈要求提供弹药和补给。但事实并非如此，对吧？我的意思是，我们已经说过这并不清晰。我想说的是：“本廷，快来”或“来吧”或无论那是什么。
And he says in broken English, the Indians are skedaddling. The Indians are running away. So Benteen thinks, he is actually cross at this. He thinks, oh, I've missed my chance. Custer is going to get all the glory after all. What a shambles. What a disgrace. Now, some writers are very critical of Benteen here. T.J. St Styles, it was an unequivocal, positive command to join Custer and an insistent demand for ammunition and supplies. But it wasn't, was it? I mean, we've said it's not clear. I think Benteen, come quickly or come on or whatever it was.
我的意思是，好吧，当然，他必须去拿弹药。但这里有一种急迫感。里面有一种隐含的紧迫性。当然，但你得去拿弹药。但这里有一种急迫感。里面有一种隐含的紧迫性。当然，但你得走错方向好几英里去拿弹药，然后再把它们带回来。不管你骑得多快，这依然一点也不清晰。
I mean, I think, okay, sure, he has to go and get the ammunition. But there is a sense of haste. There's an implied urgency there. Sure, but you've got to go and get the ammunition. But there is a sense of haste. There's an implied urgency there. Sure, but you've got to go a couple of miles of the wrong way to get the ammunition and then bring it back. And you can go as fast as you like. It's still, I don't think it's clear at all.
但本廷并没有走快。本廷磨磨蹭蹭。因为他在使性子。因为他在使性子。后来，当他们举行那场唯一的调查时——实际上那是一场关于雷诺行为的调查——本廷在证人席上多次被问到：你当时为什么磨蹭？他给出了非常矛盾的回答。正如 T·J·斯蒂尔斯所说，
But Bentin does not go fast. Bentin dawdles. Because he's in a strop. Because he's in a strop. And later on, when there was the one investigation they held, which was actually an investigation into Reno's conduct, Bentin was asked multiple times, kind of on the stand as it were, why did you dawdle? And he gave very contradictory answers. As TJ Starr says,
他声称自己当时相信卡斯特绝对安全，同时也相信他已经死了。他声称自己相信拉克塔人正在逃跑，同时也相信他们正在痛击第 7 骑兵团。所以谁知道本廷心里在想什么呢？也许他自己也不知道。你知道，在激烈的战斗和战争的迷雾中。激烈的战斗和战争的迷雾中。是的。是的。
he claimed he believed that Custer was perfectly safe and also that he was dead. He claimed he believed that the Lakotas were running away and also that they were smashing the regiment. So who knows what's going through Bentin? Maybe he doesn't know himself. You know, in the heat of battle and the fog of war. The heat of battle and the fog of war. Yeah. Yeah.
谁知道会发生什么呢？这是一场炎热的迷雾。就是这样。不管怎样，本廷算是继续前进了。大约 15 分钟后，他在一个小山包上看到了这些人。因为他顺着小溪走过来，对吧？卡斯特和雷诺就是顺着这条溪骑马下来的。所以如果要上高地，
Who knows what may happen? It's a hot fog. That's what it is. Anyway, Bentin sort of continues. And after about 15 minutes, he sees these blokes on this hill. Because he's coming down the creek, isn't he, that Custer and Reno had ridden down. So if he's going to go up to the bluffs,
他就得来到雷诺所在的地方。是的。所以他在这个山头上看到了雷诺（你知道的）。“噢，情况怎么样？”雷诺的状态糟透了。记住，他头上缠着大手帕，整个人变得跟克里斯托弗·沃肯（Christopher Walken）一样。他甚至有点在啜泣。
he's got to come down to where Reno is. Yeah. So he sees Reno on this hill, you know. Oh, how's it going? Reno is in a terrible state. Remember he's got his bandana around, he's turned into Christopher Walken. He's kind of sobbing.
“巴斯泰尔斯！他们冲我们来了。”彻底崩溃了，是的，他变成了一个彻底的废人。“我损失了一半的人。”本廷问：“那卡斯特呢？”雷诺说：“我不知道。他顺流而下去了，我再也没见过他，也没听到他的任何消息。”当然，周围现在都是拉克塔人，但其中一些人正朝着北方散去。
Barstiles! They're coming for us. A total, yeah, he's dissolved into an absolute wreck. I've lost half my men. And Bentin says, well, where's Custer? Reno, I don't know. He went off downstream, and I haven't seen or heard anything of him since. Now, of course, there are Lakota around them, but some of them are now disappearing off sort of to the north.
为什么？大概是因为他们去对付卡斯特了，或者卡斯特在采取行动，或者有什么事情发生了。本廷把写着“快来”的纸条给雷诺看，并问：“我们要不要去找卡斯特？”雷诺说：“在拿到弹药之前行动简直是疯了。”但他的手下基本上已经弹尽粮绝了。所以本廷心想：好吧，这主意大概挺不错。他后来表示，他以为 C 将军（卡斯特）能照顾好自己。
Why? Presumably because they're off dealing with Custer or Custer is making a move or something is happening. Bentin shows Reno the note that says, come quick, and says, should we go and find Custer? And Reno says, madness to move until we've got ammunition. But his men have basically run out of ammunition. So Benteen thinks, yeah, that's probably quite a good call. He said later, he supposed General Custer could take care of himself.
嗯，几乎可以肯定这是正确的决定，否则第 7 骑兵团全团都会被全歼。是的。但同样地，你也能看出其中可能也有个人因素的影响。我的意思是，如果他真的很崇拜卡斯特，也许他会为此感到更焦虑一些。所以他们留在了那个山头上，一直待到下午 5 点 20 分左右。所以天还是亮的，依然非常暖和，辎重队到了，于是他们拿到了弹药，还能听到枪声。
Well, almost certainly the correct decision, because otherwise the whole of the 7th Cavalry would have been wiped out. Yes. But equally, you can see that there may be personal influences on that as well. I mean, if he really was adored Custer, perhaps he would have been a little bit more anxious about it. So they stay there on this hill and they stayed there until about 5 20 p.m so it's still light still very warm the pack train arrives so they get their ammunition and they can hear firing
我想，对于那些想知道卡斯特活了多久的人来说，这是一个相当说明问题的细节。他们能听到远处传来的枪声——能听到山崖上隐隐传来的枪声。他们看不见那边的战况，不知道发生了什么，但他们能听到声音。事实上，许多骑兵都说：“那一定是卡斯特。他很快就会来救我们的。”是的。因为在这期间，多米尼克，他们一直遭到敌人的射击。是的，当然。
i think this is for people who are wondering how long custer lived i think this is quite a telling detail they can hear firing away to the can hear firing on the bluffs. They can't see it, what's going on, but they can hear something. And actually, numerous troopers said, that must be Custer. And he'll come and rescue us soon. Yeah. Because all the while, Dominic, they're still being fired on. Yeah, of course.
是的。所以，我的意思是，甚至连箭——如果箭射进骨头里，是很难拔出来的。是的，当然。我的意思是，那可能会要了你的命。你知道，子弹打中肚子，那可不是闹着玩的。但随后出现了非常诡异的情况，不是吗？因为他们在山崖上听到了枪击声，紧接着，他们开始听到一种略有不同密度的枪声。那是卡斯特和雷诺的部下一直使用的卡宾枪和步枪发出的“呼啸”声，其中一位中尉瓦尔姆（Varnum）这么说过。
Yes. So, I mean, even arrows, the arrow, if it goes into the bone, difficult to get out yeah of course i mean it could kill you you know in a bullet in the stomach that's not good but then very sinister development isn't there because they've heard this gunfire up on the bluffs and then soon afterwards they start hearing a slightly different sound of gunfire. It's a kind of zing sound came, one of the Lieutenant Varnum says. And it's the sound of the carbines and the rifles that the 7th Cavalry had been using.
没错，是的。这些枪正被用来对抗……是的。这表明枪声来自卡斯特的部队。是的。现在，曾有一段时间，他们中的一些人试图突围。维尔（Weir）队长曾试图带领他的连离开所谓的“雷诺山”。本廷和雷诺最后也加入了他的行列。
Right, yeah. They're being used against, yeah. It suggests that it's come from Custer's troops. Yeah. Now, there was a point where some of them tried to break out. There was Captain Weir, who had tried to lead his company off what's called Reno Hill. Bentine and Reno ended up joining him.
他们通过双筒望远镜看到，他们认为可能是印第安人在向地上的什么东西——可能是地上的人——射箭。但最终，他们在现在被称为“维尔角”的地方被一支庞大的勇士部队包围了，于是他们撤回了雷诺最初坚守的山头。而雷诺到这个时候已经彻底废了。我的意思是，他就像个婴儿一样坐在那里抱着酒瓶。他们开始用木箱、马鞍包、辎重队的零碎物品以及死去的动物等东西构筑防线。说实话，本廷一开始表现得很糟糕，因为他说“别费劲了”，而他的连队显然遭受了更多的伤亡——比其他连队多出一倍的伤亡——因为他的漫不经心。但他确实振作起来了，不是吗？
They can see through their binoculars what they think are Indians firing arrows at something on the ground, people on the ground possibly. But eventually they are besieged on what's now called Weir Point by a huge force of warriors and they withdraw back to Reno's original hill. And there Reno is just absolutely wasted by this point. I mean, he's just sitting there with his bottle like a kind of baby. And they start to create a defensive line from boxes and saddlebags and bits of the pack train and dead animals and stuff actually bentin i have to say behave very poorly at first because he said don't bother and his company apparently suffered more casualties twice as many casualties than any other because because of his insouciance. But he does send up his game, doesn't he?
他确实振作了。是的，本廷真是个经历了两重天的人，不是吗？是的。我觉得公平地说，他一开始的表现非常糟糕，但后来表现得很出色。我的意思是，他们面对的是那么多的勇士。内撒尼尔·菲尔布里克（Nathaniel Philbrick）说，其实有趣的是，奇怪的是拉克塔人从未发动冲锋，
He does. Yeah, he has a game of two halves, hasn't he, Benteen? Yeah. He starts off very poorly, I think it's fair to say, but then distinguishes himself later. I mean, they're facing so many warriors. Nathaniel Philbrick says, actually, the funny thing is, the odd thing is that Lakota never charged,
因为如果他们发动冲锋的话，早就把他们压垮了——那种罗克斯德里夫（Rorke's Drift）式的压垮。是的，他们毫无疑问会压垮防守者。好吧，本廷曾说过——当我说我们和那些红皮肤人度过了一段相当温暖的时光时，我是在陈述事实。这很英国作风，非常“相当温暖”。所以威灵顿公爵（Duke Wellington）一定会赞同这种轻描淡写的说法。夜幕降临，天黑了。他们能听到村里女人们为死者发出的哀嚎声。他们能听到鼓声。他们能听到庆祝的呐喊声。这太可怕了。
because if they had charged, they would have overwhelmed them overwhelmed that sort of rorke's drift style yeah they would undoubtedly have overwhelmed the defenders well bentin i state but the facts when i say that we had a fairly warm time with those red men that's quite british that's very fairly warm fairly warm so duke wellington would approve of such understatement So dust comes down and then it's night. And they can hear the women howling for the dead down in the village. And they can hear drums. And they can hear the cries of celebration. And it's horrible.
噢，这太可怕了。因为他们在想：黎明会带来什么？我们能坚持住吗？卡斯特在哪里？现在，本廷显然在到处对每个人说：“我了解卡斯特。我了解他的行事方式。他抛弃了我们。他逃跑了。”
Oh, it is horrible. Because they're wondering, what will dawn bring? Are we going to be able to hold out? And where is Custer? Now, Bentin clearly is going around saying to everybody, I know Custer. I know the way he behaves. He's abandoned us. He's run off.
是的，他溜了。“这绝对是标准的卡斯特风格。这太典型了。他抢到了胜利，然后就——”所以他们被困在这个山头上了。但你不觉得——我的意思是，第 7 骑兵团的步枪声突然响起来这件事——我想他们可能会认为
Yeah, he's gone off. That's absolutely classic Custer. This is typical. He's got the victory and he's, yeah. So they are stuck up on this hill. But you don't think that, I mean, the fact that 7th Cavalry rifles are suddenly have popped up. I suppose they might think
那是雷诺阵亡的手下的枪被敌人缴获了。我不知道。是的，我想也是。我觉得他们当时根本没心思去想这个。是的，也许吧。大多数人都是如此。
that it's been taken by Reno's dead. I don't know. Yeah, I suppose so. I don't think they're really thinking about it. Yeah, maybe not. Most of them.
我想他们当时都吓得魂不附体了，汤姆。是的。而且并非毫无道理。极度恐慌。所以他们在 26 日清晨醒来。他们仍然在这个山头上。
I think they're just in such a funk, Tom. Yeah. And not unreasonably. A Bali funk. So they wake up the morning of the 26th. They're still on this hill.
为了印证你刚才的观点，他们这时可以看到，下面的一些本土勇士——夏延人或拉克塔人——正穿着第 7 骑兵团的大衣。其中一些人还戴着帽子。他们戴着那种草帽。所以这算是一个明显的迹象，表明卡斯特的手下发生了不测。但实际上，他们只是看着他们然后说：“噢，也许卡斯特抛弃了我们，把一些大衣留下了。”我的意思是，谁知道呢。无论如何，他们只是
To bolster your last point, they can see at this point that some of the native warriors below, the Cheyenne or Lakota, they are wearing 7th Cavalry coats. And some of them have hats. They have the kind of straw hats. So that would be a bit of a giveaway that something untoward has happened to Custer's men. But actually, they just look at them and they say, well, maybe Custer has abandoned us and left some coats behind I mean who knows anyway they're just
被困在上面遭到射击，有箭，有枪声，而且他们没有水，对吧？没有水。天气变得越来越热，随着清晨的推移，当然。此时有 40 人受了重伤，流了很多血，当你流了大量血时，你显然会面临严重脱水的危险。他们绝望了。我的意思是，有一个人渴疯了。他们在嚼草。他们吮吸鹅卵石。他们啃咬子弹，试图刺激唾液分泌。
stuck up there being fired at arrows gunshots and they don't have water do they have no water it's getting very very hot of course because the morning proceeds now the 40 of these men are badly injured and have lost quite a lot of blood and when you've lost a lot of blood, you're obviously in serious danger of dehydration. And they are desperate. I mean, one man went mad from thirst. They are chewing grass. They suck pebbles. They gnaw bullets to try and work up saliva.
还有一个极其悲惨的故事，不是吗？关于一个腹部中弹的人。麦克韦（McVeigh）先生。他不停地哀求给点水喝。他最后甚至开出 75 美元的高价只求喝上一口水。他们说：“好吧，行。没问题。”一队敢死队员顶着敌人的步枪火力
And there's a terrible story, isn't there, of a man who's been shot in the stomach. Mr. McVeigh. Who's begging nonstop for water. And he ends up offering $75 for a drink of water. And they said, yeah, fine. Okay. A troop of graves, the rifle fire of the enemy
去弄水。从河里。带了回来。拿到了他的 75 美元。这人喝了下去，结果水直接从他肚子上的洞里渗出来了。
to go and get the water. From the river. Brings it back. Yeah. Gets his $75. The man drinks it and it just trickles out through the hole in his stomach.
是的，太惨了。但他躺下平静地死去了。所以也不算全都是坏事。所以，好吧。这取决于我们认为他的杯子是半空的还是半满的。那太惨了。但他躺下平静地死去了。所以也不算全都是坏事。所以，好吧。这取决于我们认为他的杯子是半空的还是半满的，汤姆。而且，当然，另一件事是，当人死后，尸体开始腐烂。马匹尤其如此。因为如果一马的肚子中了一枪，它的腹部就会因产生气体而肿胀。
Yeah, terrible. But he laid back and died in peace. So not all bad. So, yeah. Depends whether we think his glass was half empty. Half full there, terrible. But he laid back and died in peace. So not all bad. So, yeah. Depends whether we think his glass was half empty or half full there, Tom. And also, of course, the other thing is that when people die, they start to decompose. And this is a particular problem with horses. Because if a horse gets hit by a bullet in its stomach, it's kind of swollen with gases.
然后你会看到腐烂的血肉发生巨大的爆裂。是的，因为他们用马的尸体当做防御工事。没错，没错。现在，我们一直在——或者你特别喜欢——做出一些非常，
And you get this great explosion of putrefying flesh. Yes, because they're using the horse's bodies as a siege wall. Exactly, exactly. Now, we have been, or you in particular, you've made some pretty,
我想大多数听众都会同意，极其残酷且毫无品味的比较，将本廷队长比作你的联合主持人——这确实发生了，不是吗？但你——但你现在站出来了——但本廷队长现在绝对表现得出类拔萃。是的，干得好，多米尼克。你可以看到子弹在他周围的地上激起尘土，而他就像在阅兵式上一样镇定自若地走过我们的防线，在办完差事后，手里拿着一支卡宾枪以同样的方式走了回来。他那种漫不经心的态度在这里真的发挥得淋漓尽致，不是吗？
I think most listeners would agree, cruel and tasteless comparisons between Captain Bentine and your co-presenter that's that's true isn't it but you but you now step forward but captain bentine now absolutely distinguishes himself yes well done dominic you could see the bullets throwing up dust as they struck all around him while he as calmly as if on parade came down our lines and after his errand, returned in the same manner, carrying in his hand a carbine. His insouciance really comes into its own here, doesn't it?
你把他比作什么来着？音乐厅里反串演老太太的人还是什么的。是的。他看起来就像个女装模仿秀演员。是的，这倒挺贴切。但随后他对手下发表了一番鼓舞人心的演讲。现在是时候了，伙计们。
What did you compare him? A man playing an aunt in the music hall or something. Yeah. He looks like a female impersonator. Yeah. That's fair to say. But then he says to his men, he gives them an inspiring speech. Now's your time, men.
给他们点颜色瞧瞧。万岁，我们上！每个人都欢呼雀跃，觉得这太棒了。嗯，但并非所有人，多米尼克。不，我知道。所以有——那会是我。是的。有个家伙躺在地上哭泣，拒绝前往。
Give them hell. Hip, hip, here we go. And everybody cheers and thinks this is tremendous. Well, but not everybody, Dominic. No, I know. So there is, it would be me. Yeah. There's a guy who lies on the floor crying and refuses to go.
还有另一个家伙躲在饼干盒后面，在余生里被称为“饼干盒达德”。是的。好吧，除了那个哭泣的人之外，其余所有人都去了。还有一个家伙，他们不得不把他像一头公猪一样捆绑起来，因为他在那儿呜咽大喊。像一头公猪一样。不管怎样。
And there's another bloke who hides behind a tin of cracker boxes and for the rest of his life is known as Cracker Box Dad. Yeah. Well, all the rest of them except for the crying person. And there's also a guy who they've had to truss up like a hog because he was whimpering and shouting. Like a hog. Anyway.
噢，听起来太可怕了。他说：“我们必须去弄水。”许多人站了出来，因为受到他那种漫不经心的态度的鼓舞。万岁。我们上！他们冒着枪林弹雨下到河边，用行军锅打水，然后折返。没有一个人中弹。
Oh, it just sounds awful. He says, we've got to go and get water. Loads of them step forward because they're inspired by his insouciance. Hip, hip. Here we go. And they go down and they get water in their kettles from the river under fire. And they return. Not one of them is hit.
他们全都获得了荣誉勋章。是的，实至名归。表现非常出色。于是白昼流逝。天气热得难以置信。他们有了一点水。他们还在坚守。最终，在大约三点钟的时候，
They all got medals of honor. Yeah, as well they should. Very good behavior. So the day wears on. It's incredibly hot. They've got a little bit of water. They're still holding out. And eventually, at about three o'clock,
枪声似乎减弱了。此时实际发生的情况是，拉克塔人的营地正在移动。他们正朝着大角山（Bighorn Mountains）方向撤离。他们已经玩够了。事实上，有些人向外眺望。有个叫查尔斯·温德霍夫（Charles Windhoff）的人向外看去，他说：
the firing seems to die down. What's actually happening at this point is the Lakota village is now moving. They are moving off towards the Bighorn Mountains. They've had their fun. And actually, some of them look out. There's a guy called Charles Windhoff who looked out and he says,
“我们看到了成千上万的人。我们简直不敢相信，成千上万的步行和骑马的人，带着大型营地的所有行头，正缓慢地向南移动。这就像某种《圣经》中的出埃及记，以色列人进入埃及，一个庞大的部族在行军。”许多人此时认为，卡斯特现在一定带着援军赶到了，所以他把印第安人吓跑了。因此他们依然死守在山头上，他们紧紧缩在一起，
we saw thousands. We couldn't believe it, thousands upon thousands of people on foot and on horseback with all the trappings of a great camp moving slowly southward. It was like some biblical exodus, the Israelites moving into Egypt, a mighty tribe on the march. Many of them think at this point, well, custom must now be arriving with reinforcements and he has scared them off so they still wait on their hill they're kind of huddled on their hill they don't
当然不敢冒任何风险。印第安人撤离确实花了相当长的时间。夜幕降临，黎明到来。他们从山头上望出去，只看到一些帐篷的残骸和一些废墟，然后他们看到一团尘土从北方滚滚而来。他们心里想：噢，不！这是更多的敌人吗？是拉克塔人卷土重来吗？但随后，尘土越来越近，他们认为那是士兵——是美国陆军的士兵。谢天谢地！现在，就在美国陆军抵达之前，这真是一场堪称罗克斯德里夫战役风格的壮举，不是吗？他们在这个山头上坚守住了。在雷诺的指挥下，他们曾一度险些陷入彻底完全的恐慌和混乱。实际上，本廷抛开他所有的令人讨厌之处不谈——
want to take any risks of course it does take the indians quite a long time to move off so night falls dawn comes they look out from the hill and they just see the remnants of some lodges and some debris and then they see a dust cloud coming from the north and they're like oh no is this more is this the lakota attacking again but then no the dust cloud comes closer and they think it's soldiers it's u.s army soldiers thank goodness now just before the the US Army arrives, it is quite a Rorke's Drift style achievement, isn't it? They have held out on this hill. They were so close under Reno to complete and utter panic and chaos. And actually, Bentine, for all his malignance.
他成了当之无愧的英雄。他稳住了他们的军心。是的。我想其中大约有 350 人仍然活着。这就像我们第一次做现场演出时，我吓得语无伦次一样。是吗？我当时不得不像一头公猪一样被捆起来，而你却展现出了真正的自我。你只是非常冷静、非常有分寸地走上舞台，让我感到无地自容，而我则从饼干盒后面爬了出来。这就是当时的写照。这就是为什么你被授予了戈尔德亨格（Goldhanger）荣誉勋章。
He's the hero of the hour. He has steadied their nerve. Yeah. 350 of them, I think, are still alive. It's like when we did our first time doing a live show and i was gibbering were you i had to be trussed up like a hog and you were just you came into your own you just stepped out onto the stage very cool very measured and you shamed me and i crawled out from behind the cracker box and that's what it's like. And that's why you've been given the Goldhanger Medal of Honor.
那种恶毒，就为了那一刻——为了那光荣的 90 秒……转瞬即逝。是的，就这样烟消云散了。我想……刻薄的讽刺烟消云散了。是的，这是一个崭新的多米尼克。西奥在聊天区写道：“尖锐的智慧”。我喜欢这个评价，西奥。
The malevolence for just that, for 90 glorious... For a fleeting moment. Yeah, it just vanished. And I thought... The cruel cynicism melted away. Yeah, this is a new Dominic. Theo has written in the chat, cynical intelligence. I like that, Theo.
谢谢。不管怎样。他们说：“干得好，本廷。”是的，干得好，本廷。所以，实际上是特里（Terry）将军到了。他在汽船上吃完了晚饭或什么的。是的，他用餐巾擦了擦胡子。他终于大驾光临了。
Thank you. Anyway. They say, well done, Benteen. Yeah, well done, Benteen. So it is actually General Terry who is arriving. He's finished his dinner on the steamboat or whatever it is. Yes, he's brushed his whiskers with his napkin. And he's finally deigned to turn up.
其实，这话有点刻薄。他们进攻得太快了，不是吗？他们本该等他的。他们为他发出三声欢呼，他骑马过来时脱下了帽子。有些人注意到他在哭，特里将军竟然在哭，而他们甚至不知道原因。接着，本廷那种良好的行为彻底烟消云散了。
Actually, that's very harsh. They attacked too quickly, didn't they? They should have waited for him. They give three cheers for him, and he takes his hat off as he rides up to them. And some of them notice that he's crying, that General Terry is crying, and they actually don't know why. And then Benteen's good behavior vanishes completely.
坏透了的本廷。他的态度急转直下，因为他对特里说：“卡斯特在哪儿？”特里将军回答：“据我所知，他连同手下所有官兵一起，阵亡在下方大约四英里处的这道山岭上。”这是一个极其庄严的时刻。现在，换作任何其他人，或许都会陷入沉默？也许会有一刻的反思？本廷会吗？不。
Bad, bad Bentine. It turns because he says to Terry, where's Custer? And General Terry says, to the best of my knowledge and belief, he lies on this ridge about four miles below here with all his command killed. It's an incredibly solemn moment. Now, anybody else would perhaps fall silent here? A moment of reflection, perhaps? Does Benteen? No.
本廷说：“不，不可能。卡斯特没死。我了解卡斯特那套把戏。我觉得他就在大角河下游的某个地方放马呢。在沃希托（Washita）战役中，他就曾一走了之，把一部分部下扔在后面。我想他这次又这么干了。”是的，坏透了的本廷。
Benteen says, no, no way. Custer's not dead. I know Custer's bad. He says, I think he's somewhere down the Bighorn grazing his horses. At the Battle of the Washita, he went off and left part of his command. I think he would do it again. Yeah. Bad, bad Bente.
特里打断了他。不。特里对此非常生气。“你弄错了。你带上你的连队，去死者躺着的地方亲自查证一下。”所以这是一次极其可怕的行程，不是吗？是的。因为本廷带着部下下到山谷，穿过村庄，登上高地。
Terry cuts him off. No. Terry is very cross at this. You are mistaken. You will take your company and go down where the dead are lying and investigate for yourself. And so this is a horrible journey, isn't it? Yeah. Because Bente takes his men and they go down into the valley, through the village, and up onto the heights.
在走进村庄时，他们发现了第 7 骑兵团的各种遗物。比如某个人的头颅和身体各部分。很明显，尸体曾被绳索拖拽过，已经彻底支离破碎了。所以手臂和大腿都散落得到处都是。当他们穿过平原时，他们开始意识到，无论在哪里看到像仙人掌一样从草丛中刺出的成簇的箭矢，那就是一名死去的骑兵。内脏随处可见。残肢、头首，应有尽有。那里还有一根竿子，上面挂着三颗被烧得面目全非、无法辨认的焦黑人头。
And going down into the village, they find all kinds of remnants of the 7th Cavalry. So there's a head of someone and his body parts. And it's clearly been dragged on a rope and it's just completely disintegrated. So the arms and the legs have all just kind of fallen off. And as they're going across the plain, they start to realize that wherever they see clumps of arrows like cacti coming up from the grass, this is a dead trooper. There are entrails everywhere. There are limbs, heads, whatever. And there's a pole with three charred human heads who are so burned that they can't be recognized.
然后他们登上山坡，起初以为是一头野牛被杀了，到处都是野牛皮和剥了皮的野牛胴体。但当他们走近时，他们才意识到，他们以为的野牛皮实际上是死去的战马，而他们以为剥了皮的野牛胴体，其实是卡斯特手下士兵的尸体。是的，他们四处查看，
And then they go up onto the slopes and they think that a buffalo has been killed and that there are buffalo skins everywhere and skinned buffalo carcasses. But then they come up closer and they realize that what they had thought were buffalo skins are in fact the horses that are dead and that what they thought were the skinned buffalo carcasses are the bodies of custer's men yeah and they go around and they
数出了 197 具士兵的尸体。是的，而且很多时候，如果这些士兵的脸还能辨认的话，他们的表情都带着极度的痛苦、恐惧和惊恐，双眼圆睁。当然，他们来到了卡斯特的遗体旁。他会放下斧头（既往不咎）吗？没有。他对死去的指挥官表现出轰轰烈烈的英雄主义敬意了吗，多米尼克？还是说他说了什么？不，他没有。他说——他让自己掉价了，本廷说道：“他就在那儿。
count 197 dead soldiers yeah and quite and often there insofar as the men's faces survive, their expressions are one of terrible agony, fear, dread, eyes bulging. And of course, they're down at Custer's corpse. And does he bury the hatchet? No. Does he come up with a ringing acknowledgement of the heroism of his dead commander, Dominic? Or what does he say? No, he doesn't. He says, you know, he lets himself down, does Bentine. He says, there he is.
愿上帝诅咒他。他再也不会打仗了。”所以卡斯特倒在离他的兄弟汤姆很近的地方。汤姆的头骨被彻底砸碎了，不是吗？他的尸体遭到了可怕的虐待。他较年轻的弟弟波士顿（Boston）也在那里。还有他 18 岁的侄子奥蒂·里德（Autie Reed）。卡斯特本人奇怪的是并没有遭到特别严重的虐待。
God damn him. He will never fight anymore. So Custer is lying very close to his brother, Tom. Tom's skull has been totally smashed in, hasn't it? And his body has been horrifically mutilated. His younger brother, Boston, is also there. And his nephew, 18-year-old, Autie Reed. Custer himself, oddly, has not particularly been mutilated.
他中了两枪，一枪在胸口心脏附近，一枪在太阳穴。一枪在心脏，一枪在太阳穴。他被剥光了衣服，他的大腿被割开了一道口子——这是拉克塔人的传统——还有一个细节为了保护他妻子的感情而被隐瞒了，不是吗？他的生殖器被箭刺中了。因此，一支箭被插入了他的体内。还有一件事，他没有被剥头皮。没有。所以问题来了——他们本该想要长发的头皮，但他的头发并不长，而且也没有什么特别的理由能让印第安人认出他来。不，普遍的看法是，他大概没有被认出来。所以我们也许会在下半场讨论这个问题，尝试弄清楚当时到底发生了什么。
He's been hit by two bullets, one in the chest, round about the heart, one in the temple. He the heart one in the temple he's been stripped naked he's been stripped his thigh has been cut which was a low-coder tradition and there is one more detail which was suppressed wasn't it to spare his wife's feelings yeah that his penis has been stabbed with an arrow so an arrow has been inserted into him one thing uh he has not been scalped no and so the question hangs over they would have wanted long hair scalp but of course his hair is not long and there's no particular reason why they would have recognized him no i think it's generally thought isn't it he probably hadn't been recognized so we'll maybe discuss this in the second half where we try and work out what actually happened.
并且讨论是否真的存在过“最后一战”，如果有的话，它有多英勇。好吧，那我们中场休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、影评以及八卦猛料。
Yeah. And discuss whether there was a last stand and if so, how heroic it was. Okay. So we will see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目以及现场门票的优先抢购权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，多米尼克，卡斯特的最后一战。我们说过这是世界历史上最具标志性的时刻之一，但我们对它究竟了解多少？我们对之前发生的事情又了解多少？
And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History and Dominic, Custer's last stand. We've said one of the absolutely totemic moments of world history, but what do we actually know about it? And what do we know about the events that preceded it?
好吧，你还记得我们最后一次见到卡斯特是在 6 月 24 日下午 3 点 30 分，当时那个小号手带着给本廷的纸条骑马离去。我觉得可以说，这大概是任何幸存者最后一次看到活着的他了。所以，关于卡斯特和他的最后一战，汤姆——正如 19 世纪末 20 世纪初所有人称呼的那样，美国的温泉关——从那一刻起，和卡斯特在一起的人没有一个幸存下来。他们全都死了。所以这件事可以说已经被分析得透彻不能再透彻了。我的意思是，被不同的历史学家写进了成百上千本书中。
Well, you'll recall that the last we saw of Custer was at 3.30 on the 24th of June when that trumpeter rode off with the message for Bentin. And I think it's fair to say that probably is the last time that anybody, any survivor sees him alive. So, of course, the thing with Custer in his last stand, Tom, the American thermopoly as, you know, all those people called it in the sort of late 19th, early 20th century. Nobody who was with Custer from that moment on survived. They're all dead. So it's been analysed, as it were, to death. I mean, in hundreds and hundreds of books by different historians.
最终，唯一诚实的回答只能是：我们永远无从得知，我们永远不会知道，做到完全确定是不可能的。我的意思是，你会读到一些书，我们俩都读过，里面给出了极其详细的描述。“他喝了酷爱饮品，你知道的，闪过银幕……”但没有人——他们绝不可能知道这些。话虽如此，我们其实还有两类信息来源，不至于完全陷入无知。
And ultimately, the only honest answer can be that we can never know, that we will never know, that it is impossible to be certain. I mean, you will read books, we've both read them, they give extremely detailed accounts. He turned up the Kool-Aid, you know, across the screen. But no one, they can't possibly do that. Except having said that, there are two sources of information that we're not completely lost in ignorance.
因为我们确实有目击者的证词，也就是那些与第 7 骑兵团作战的人的证词。是的，现在很明显，他们可能会说他们听众想听的话。是的，你知道的，他们可能会美化他们所看到的东西，进行吹嘘。进行吹嘘，所以这并不可靠。但另一件事是考古证据。是的，当然。1983 年发生了一场大火，不是吗？那场大火席卷了战场遗址。
Because we do have eyewitness accounts, which are those who fought against the seventh cavalry yeah now obviously they may be saying what their listeners want them to say yes you know they may embellish what they saw be boasting be boasting so that's not reliable but the other thing is that the evidence of archaeology yes of course and 1983 there was a fire wasn't there that kind of ravished the battlefield site. And a lot of archaeological work was done. So they went in, the archaeologists, and they kind of found military kit that had been abandoned.
随后进行了大量的考古工作。于是考古学家们进驻了遗址，他们找到了被遗弃的军事装备。
And there's a very good book, Richard Fox's Archaeology, History, and Custer's last battle, which I think has shed a good deal more light on what happened than there was before that fire. Because it is such a mythic battle, of course, there are all kinds of myths around it. Yeah. So there's two really peculiar stories which you should deal with probably straight away. So there is one group of witnesses who are not people who fought against Custer, who are the scouts. There are away and all the shambles and all of that stuff. And Custer just watched and did nothing from the bluffs. Now, this is what at the time was an incendiary story. Remember, there's a lot of the people from that battle are still alive at that point. And Edward Curtis was really shocked by this story because, of course, this would transform the image of Custer that he had knowingly, presumably in an attempt to get all the glory for himself, had knowingly let Reno get into trouble while doing nothing to help him.
有一本非常好的书，理查德·福克斯（Richard Fox）写的《考古学、历史与卡斯特的最后一战》（Archaeology, History, and Custer's Last Battle），我认为这本书比那场大火之前更能说明当时到底发生了什么。由于这是一场如此神话般的战役，周围自然环绕着各种各样的神话。是的。这里有两个非常奇怪的故事，你可能应该立刻处理一下。有一群目击者不是与卡斯特作战的人，而是侦察兵。他们在一旁看着所有的混乱和这一切。而卡斯特只是在山崖上看着，什么也没做。在当时，这是一个极具煽动性的故事。记住，那场战役中的许多人在当时都还活着。爱德华·柯蒂斯（Edward Curtis）对这个故事感到非常震惊，因为如果这是真的，它将颠覆卡斯特的形象——他为了独占功劳，明知雷诺陷入了困境却故意袖手旁观，见死不救。
And actually, Curtis sent this story before publishing it. He sent it to Theodore Roosevelt because he knew Roosevelt was a great enthusiast for stories of the West. And he said to Roosevelt, what do you think? And Roosevelt said, well, I don't really believe it. But that said, anything is possible in the battle. Anyway, Curtis didn't publish it at first. It only came out much later on. And I think most historians now are suspicious of it.
事实上，柯蒂斯在发表这个故事之前，把它寄给了西奥多·罗斯福（Theodore Roosevelt），因为他知道罗斯福是西部故事的超级爱好者。他对罗斯福说：“你觉得怎么样？”罗斯福说：“嗯，我其实不太相信。话虽如此，战场上什么都有可能发生。”无论如何，柯蒂斯起初并没有发表它。直到很久以后它才被曝光。我想现在大多数历史学家都对它持怀疑态度。
They don't know why the scouts would have made it up or maybe got it wrong or who knows it would have been hard for custer perhaps get down there it might exactly now the other story even stranger there was a guy called private peter thompson who was 22 he was part of custer's company but he fell behind part of his battalion i should say and then he fell behind his horse was knackered he stopped to put on spurs to kind of encourage his horse. And some Lakota warriors came near him. So he went and hid in a ravine. And there's lots of sort of faffing around.
他们不知道侦察兵为什么要编造这个故事，或者也许是记错了，或者谁知道呢。卡斯特当时可能很难赶到那个地方。可能确实如此。现在，另一个故事甚至更奇怪。有个叫彼得·汤普森（Peter Thompson）的二等兵，当时 22 岁。他是卡斯特连队的成员，但他落后了——准确地说是落后于他的营。接着他的马累垮了，他停下来钉马掌，以便催促他的马。
But later on, he comes out of his hiding place and he sees, he said, he saw a crow scout dragging a bound Lakota woman near the banks of the Little Bighorn. That's not impossible that a crow scout could have captured a hostage or something. And then he says he saw Custer alone on his horse talking to them. And Custer waved and then rode on. And no one knows what to make of this story. I mean, some people say, is it like a hallucination? Was Custer just going off and scouting on his own for a moment? And that's what he saw? I don't think it's true. Because I think that in the wake of the death of a famous person in a great disaster, people are always fabricating stories about how they saw him.
一些拉克塔勇士靠近了他。于是他躲进了一个沟壑里。中间有很多瞎折腾。但后来，他从藏身处出来，他说他看到一个克罗族（Crow）侦察兵在小大角河岸边拖着一个被捆绑的拉克塔妇女。克罗族侦察兵抓到一个质押人质什么的，这并非不可能。然后他说他看到卡斯特独自骑在马上跟他们说话。卡斯特挥了挥手，然后骑马走了。没有人知道该怎么看待这个故事。我的意思是，有人说，这就像是幻觉吗？卡斯特当时是不是独自一人去侦察了一会儿？这就是他看到的？我不觉得这是真的。因为我认为，在一个名人在重大灾难中丧生之后，人们总是会捏造关于他们如何目击到他的故事。
Of course. Because there are, of course, stories that Custer survived Little Big Hornet. He's now living with Elvis. Yeah, exactly. Captain Smith. Yes. Captain Smith of the Titanic. Right.
当然。因为，当然，甚至还有传言说卡斯特在小大角战役中幸存下来了，他现在正和猫王一起生活。是的，没错。史密斯船长。是的。泰坦尼克号的史密斯船长。对。
No, I think, I mean, we just don't know. Of course, the other thing is that from 1876 onwards, as soon as the story reaches the East Coast, it is big business to tell cluster stories,
不，我想，我们就是不知道。当然，另一件事是，从 1876 年开始，一当消息传到东海岸，讲述卡斯特的故事就成了一笔大生意，
isn't it? Of course. So who knows? Anyway, let's assume that both put those stories to one side because there's no way of proving them.
不是吗？当然。所以谁知道呢？总之，我们假设把这两个故事都放到一边，因为根本无法证明它们。
I think we can get a vague sense, can't we, if you sort of put all the different accounts together and see what they think. Should we just describe the topography again? Go on. Well, it's just, I mean, that is the most important thing. In 500 episodes, I've never known you such an enthusiast for the topography. I'll be honest. I often find it a real struggle to understand battles. Yeah. So in front
我想我们可以大致猜到，如果你把各种不同的说法拼凑起来看看他们的看法。我们要不要再描述一下地形？好啊。好吧，其实这才是最关键的。在制作了500集播客后，我从没见过你对地形这么热衷。说实话，我经常觉得理解战役真的很吃力。好吧。所以在我
of me, I have the Osprey classic battles guide to the little bighorn. And I think these are excellent. I never thought we'd reach this moment. I know, but they give you wonderful maps with arrows and things, but they also show you the terrain. So I'm looking at it now. So there is the little bighorn river snaking through. You've got the plain. You've got the village on the, what is it? It's the west side, haven't you? Yes, the west side of the river. And Custer's over on the east side of the river. So that's the side that Reno is on.
面前，我有奥斯佩里的《小大角之战经典战役指南》。我觉得这些书太棒了。我从没想过我们会迎来这一刻。我知道，它们为你提供了带有箭头等标记的精美地图，但它们也向你展示了地形。所以我现在正在看它。看，小大角河蜿蜒流过。有平原。村庄在，什么来着？在西侧，对吧？是的，在河的西侧。而卡斯特在河的东侧。所以那是雷诺所在的一侧。
He retreats back across the river to the east side, and he makes his stand up on the heights. Custer is already up on the bluffs, up on the heights. So he is galloping along the heights. The heights are scored by ravines, by by creeks so it's not a kind of continuous race but the bluffs that look over the village it's quite difficult to get down from them yes it is so there is a river a coulee yeah so you could go down that but essentially the challenge is how do you get down to the river and from the river into the village?
他退回河的东侧，在高地上据守。卡斯特已经在断崖上了，在高地上。所以他沿着高地策马疾驰。高地上布满了峡谷和小溪，所以这不是一场连续的赛跑，但俯瞰村庄的峭壁，要从上面下来相当困难。是的，确实如此。所以有一条河，一条干谷，你可以从那里下去，但基本上，挑战在于你如何下到河边，再从河边进入村庄？
Because I guess the assumption has to be that Custer is looking to take hostages. He's looking to round up women and children, as he's done before at the Wishing Man. Because he's done it before. And because it's a tactic that's proven to work. So I think, and lots of people have written about this, think it is plausible that Custer probably at this point, we're talking what, 3.30, 4 o'clock? Yeah. Led a feint against the village or a move against the village.
因为我猜大家一定会假设卡斯特是想抓人质。他想把妇女和儿童赶到一起，就像他以前在华希塔（Wishing Man）所做的那样。因为他以前做过。而且因为事实证明这是一种行之有效的战术。所以我想，很多人都对此进行过写作，他们认为卡斯特当时很可能——我们在说几点？下午3点半、4点？对。对村庄发动了佯攻或采取了行动。
Well, maybe not a feint. No, maybe not a feint. Maybe he's going down there to go and grab some women. Right. Could be, some historians think possibly to draw people off from Reno. He's trying to help Reno, actually. Other people think, no, Reno's beside the point. Well, he wouldn't know about Reno, would he?
嗯，也许不是佯攻。不，也许不是佯攻。也许他去那是为了抓一些妇女。对。也有可能，一些历史学家认为他可能是为了把人从雷诺身边引开。他其实是在试图帮助雷诺。另一些人则认为，不，雷诺根本无关紧要。好吧，他不会知道雷诺的事，对吧？
Well, we don't know. We just don't know what he's seen. We don't know that he saw Reno, but it's possible he could later have seen him, right? It's about four miles away. Yeah, I guess that's true. Over Bluffs. I just don't think you've seen him. Now, I want to say what probably happened. We have very sort of disorganized and contradictory accounts from Lakota. Should we do it in order? Yeah. Before we get into the details of whether or not he goes down to the Ford and whether he dies there or whatever. Go on then, Tom. So there's a hill that will come to be called Calhoun Hill, isn't there? And this is where a large body of his
嗯，我们不知道。我们只是不知道他看到了什么。我们不知道他是否看到了雷诺，但他后来有可能看到，对吧？大约四英里外。嗯，我想也是。隔着断崖。我只是觉得你没看见他。现在，我想说说可能发生的情况。我们对拉科塔人说法的了解非常零散且相互矛盾。我们按顺序讲好吗？好的。在我们讨论他到底有没有去浅滩，以及他是不是死在那里之类细节之前。那就继续吧，汤姆。所以有一座后来被称为卡尔霍恩山的山丘，对吧？这里驻扎着他的一大批
troops are stationed. Yes. Under a guy called Captain Keogh, who had fought against Garibaldi. And he's a very handsome man, the most handsome man. The handsomest man in the regiment. Yes. And he also has with him the eponymous Lieutenant Calhoun, after whom the hill is named, and who had been sent a cake by his wife. God, yeah. And he has ridden into the battle with this cake and nobody knows
部队。是的。指挥官是一个叫基奥（Keogh）的上尉，他曾与加里波第作战。他是个非常英俊的男子，最英俊的男子。团里最英俊的男子。是的。和他在一起的还有同名的卡尔霍恩中尉，这座山就是以他的名字命名的，他的妻子曾给他寄过蛋糕。天哪，是的。他带着这个蛋糕骑马上了战场，没有人知道
what happens to it so presumably the lakota take it yeah do they eat it and then brush their teeth with custer's toothbrush that's what i would have done it's one of the great unknowns isn't it so calhoun hill is kind of the southern end and custer is moving northwards of a ridge of hills. Yes, it is. That's right. I think it's called Battle Ridge today. So Custer probably leaves some men, these men under Keogh, on that hill. He further divides his battalion. I mean, Custer cannot stop dividing up his troops.
它最后怎么处理了，所以大概是被拉科塔人拿走了吧。他们把它吃掉了，然后用卡斯特的牙刷刷牙？如果是我，我就会这么做。这是最大的未解之谜之一，对吧？所以卡尔霍恩山算是南端，而卡斯特正沿着一处山脊向北移动。是的，没错。没错。我想现在它被称为战役山脊（Battle Ridge）。所以卡斯特可能在那个山丘上留下了一些人，也就是基奥手下的这些人。他进一步分割了他的营。我是说，卡斯特总是忍不住分割他的部队。
But there is a point where they're all on the hill and this is where Boston Custer joins them. Yeah. So he's come up with his his supplies and things it depends which account you read there are some people who think custer went down twice to the river so he probably went initially this was his plan he went down to scope it out comes back up or was perhaps driven back up we don't know don't know by lakota now actually tom we should say everything from this point onwards it it's possible, of course, that from this point onwards, Custer is dead.
但有一个时刻，他们都在山上，波士顿·卡斯特（Boston Custer）就是在这里加入了他们。是的。所以他带着补给品什么的赶了过来。这取决于你读的是哪种说法，有些人认为卡斯特去过两次河边，所以他可能最初是这么计划的：他下去侦察一番，然后退回来，或者可能是被赶回来的，我们不知道。拉科塔人赶回来的？我们不知道。不过说真的，汤姆，我们应该说明，从这一刻起，
Because there are some Lakota who say, well, the battle didn't take, there was no last stand and no battle. We dealt with Custer and his men straight away. It took 20 minutes, enough time for a hungry man to eat a meal. Or as one person says, it took as long as it takes the sun to travel the width of a lodge pole. Again, 15, 20 minutes. Although the question then is how does Custer's body get up on the... Right. So I think it's unlikely that he's killed, as some people suggest,
当然，卡斯特有可能从这一刻起就已经死了。因为有些拉科塔人说，战斗根本没有发生过，没有所谓的最后抵抗，也没有战斗。我们直接解决了卡斯特和他的手下。只用了20分钟，也就是一个饥饿的人吃顿饭的时间。或者正如一个人所说，它花的时间相当于太阳走过一根鹿皮帐篷杆宽度的时间。同样是15、20分钟。尽管随之而来的问题是，卡斯特的尸体怎么会到……对吧。所以我觉得他像有些人所说的那样，死在
down at the ford, down at the river. Right. That is a theory, that there was no last stand and that the whole thing just disintegrates because Custer dies early. But I just think that's it. I don't understand how his body would have ended up on top of the hill behind a horse. I think that's in defiance of some of the archaeological evidence, isn't it? Yes, I think so.
浅滩或河边的可能性不大。对，这是一种理论，认为根本没有最后的抵抗，一切都在卡斯特早早阵亡后彻底崩溃了。但我只是觉得不会这样。我不明白他的尸体怎么会最终躺在山顶上一匹马的后面。我认为这违背了一些考古证据，不是吗？是的，我也这么觉得。
And the fact that there are so many shell casings on the top of this ridge. So it's plausible, given that also that his men, Reno's men, heard the firing going on to, what, 5.30 or so, I think. So it's plausible people think that by about five o'clock custer is on this calhoun hill with keo and they are it's probably maybe it's about this point that custer realized oh god this is actually not you know i mean it's an interesting question isn't it when was the point because at 3 30 he thinks he's going to win. And he's dead probably by six, certainly by six.
而且在这个山脊的顶部有那么多的弹壳。因此，考虑到他的手下、雷诺的手下听到枪声一直持续到——大概5点半左右，我想。所以人们认为，到下午5点左右，卡斯特已经带着基奥在卡尔霍恩山上了，他们——可能也就是在这个时候，卡斯特意识到，天哪，这其实不对劲，你知道我的意思吗？这是一个有趣的问题，对吧？什么时候意识到的？因为在3点半时，他还觉得自己会赢。而他大概在6点前就死了，肯定在6点前。
So at some point during that afternoon, it must suddenly have dawned on him and his men that they were massively outnumbered and they'd made a terrible miscalculation. But this is when he then thinks, I'll have another crack at the village. Maybe again, or maybe it's the first time. Which is so Custer.
所以在那天下午的某个时刻，他和他的手下一定突然意识到，他们在人数上处于绝对劣势，他们犯了一个可怕的误算。但正是在这个时候，他想着：“我要再去袭击一次村庄。”也许是再次袭击，或者这才是第一次。这太符合卡斯特的作风了。
Yeah. You're outnumbered, you're outgunned, maybe 15 to one. I'll just go down, attack the village, take a load of hostages. What's the problem? There must have been a moment when that gambit of going down to the village to take the hostages changes from being something that you're doing because you're going to win. And this will be a way to enable that to being a desperate. This is the only way of preserving your your life so he does go down there and he never crosses the river and there's all kinds of slaughter yeah he's brought along a
是的。你寡不敌众，火力不如人，可能是15比1的劣势。我还是下去袭击村庄，抓一堆人质吧。有什么问题吗？一定有过这样一个时刻：去村庄抓人质的这场豪赌，从“因为我要赢而去做”并且“这将是实现胜利的一种方式”，变成了绝望之举。这是保住你性命的唯一方法。所以他确实下去了，但他从未过河，那里发生了各种各样的屠杀。是的，他带了一个
journalist obviously because he wouldn't want to be fighting a battle without a journalist to report it and this is a guy called mark kellogg and this seems to be when he died because his body is found down there yeah so there are definitely bodies down by the ford, down by the river. Up on the hill now at this point, Crazy Horse, according to some of the Lakota accounts, has joined the fray, is leading people against Captain Keogh. Well, no. Oh, you have different accounts, Tom? Well, no. I mean, he is, but people may be wondering what are the Lakota doing while Custer is galloping up and down hills and people are getting out their cake and things like that. And the answer is that, again, Crazy Horse is not rushing immediately into battle. He's communing. He is sprinkling dust over himself. He spends 20 minutes kind of just getting himself in focus and then he's off again and he seems to have led warriors up a coulee so up a ravine love a coulee and gall two of whose wives and three of whose children had been killed by the first volley from reno's
记者，显然，因为他可不想打仗却没有记者来报道。这个人叫马克·凯洛格（Mark Kellogg），他好像就是在这个时候死的，因为人们在下面找到了他的尸体。是的，浅滩和河边确实有尸体。此时此刻，在山上，根据一些拉科塔人的说法，疯马（Crazy Horse）已经加入了战局，正在率领众人对抗基奥上尉。嗯，不对。哦，你有不同的说法吗，汤姆？没有。我是说，他是加入了，但人们可能会好奇，当卡斯特在山丘上策马狂奔、大家掏出蛋糕等东西时，拉科塔人在干什么？答案是，疯马同样没有立刻冲入战斗。他在与神灵沟通。他在自己身上撒尘土。他花了20分钟让自己的心神专注下来，然后才出发。他似乎带领着勇士们顺着一条干谷——
men when they attacked the young papa end of the the village. He is going the other way. And it does seem that the goal is to surround Calhoun Hill where Keo is and Calhoun. And they seem to be doing this quite successfully, even as Custer is riding back up to what will become Last Stand Hill. One reason they're doing it successfully, by the way, we know from the archaeology that the Indians, the Lakota, the Cheyenne, are very well armed by comparison with Custer's men. Remember, the Custer's men have these terrible carbines. They overheat, and when they overheat, they stop working or they,
喜欢干谷——向上冲去。高尔（Gall）的两个妻子和三个孩子在雷诺手下进攻村庄年轻帕帕（papa）端时被第一轮齐射打死。他正朝另一个方向走去。而且看起来他们的目标是包围基奥和卡尔霍恩所在的卡尔霍恩山。他们似乎把这一点做得相当成功，甚至在卡斯特骑马返回日后被称为“最后抵抗之山”（Last Stand Hill）的地方时也是如此。顺便说一句，他们之所以能成功的一个原因，我们从考古学中得知，印第安人——拉科塔人、夏延人——与卡斯特的手下相比，装备要精良得多。记住，卡斯特的手下拿着那些糟糕的卡宾枪。它们会过热，一过热就停止工作，或者，
I don't know, go off in your face or something. But also, they're single shot. Now, we know from the archaeology that the Native Americans had 43 different types of weapons. And I read, a startlingly large number of warriors, perhaps as many as 300, possessed modern repeating rifles manufactured by Henry and Winchester, capable of firing 17 rounds without reloading. So they're outgunned. I mean, they're massively outgunned. And Crazy Horses banned, Gauls banned. They're kind of surrounding Calhoun Hill. They are able to, from behind rocks, shoot.
我不知道，甚至会炸膛什么的。而且，它们是单发的。现在，我们从考古学中得知，美洲原住民拥有43种不同类型的武器。我读到过，数量惊人的勇士——多达300人——拥有由亨利和温彻斯特制造的现代连发步枪，能够在不重新装填的情况下发射17发子弹。所以他们在火力上处于劣势。我是说，他们在火力上完全处于劣势。疯马的手下、高尔的手下，他们正在包围卡尔霍恩山。他们能够躲在岩石后面进行射击。
They are hidden. The 7th Cavalry are exposed. As you said, many of them have better firearms. And the point comes, I think, when Gaul decides, okay, let's storm it. And they rush up the Southern approaches to Calhoun Hill and, you know, they're blazing away and the seventh cavalry just disintegrate. Yeah.
他们隐藏得很好。第七骑兵队则暴露在外。正如你所说，他们中的许多人拥有更好的火器。然后时机到了，我想，当高尔决定“好吧，我们发起冲锋吧”。他们冲上卡尔霍恩山的南坡，你知道，他们火力全开，第七骑兵队就这样彻底崩溃了。是的。
They're terrified. Some of them shoot themselves. One of the braves who takes part says it looked like a stampede of Buffalo. Quite a lot of the codes in their accounts say, um, the American troopers seemed like they were drunk or they acted like they were children or they became foolish. Some of them tried to surrender, raise their hands. Some of them shot themselves rather than fall into enemy
他们吓坏了。有些人自杀了。一个参与其中的勇士说，这看起来就像是一场野牛大溃逃。许多拉科塔人在他们的叙述中说，美洲骑兵看起来像是喝醉了，或者他们的行为像小孩子，或者变得愚蠢起来。有些人试图投降，举起双手。有些人宁愿落入敌人
hands or started begging for mercy. Standing Bear, somebody who fought in this battle, told his son, when we rode into those soldiers, I felt really sorry for them. They looked so frightened. Many of them lay on the ground with their blue eyes open, waiting to be killed. But there's also Ironhawk, who later explains why he had pounded a trooper's skull to little smithereens.
手中也不愿投降，选择了自杀，或者开始乞求饶命。站立熊（Standing Bear），一个参加过这场战役的人，对他的儿子说：“当我们骑马冲向那些士兵时，我真的为他们感到难过。他们看起来太害怕了。他们中有许多人躺在地上，蓝色的眼睛睁得大大的，等待着被杀死。”但也有铁鹰（Ironhawk），他后来解释了自己为什么要把一个骑兵的头骨砸得粉碎。
And he said, these white men wanted it. They called for it, and I let them have it. Well, it's important to remember that. I called for it and I let them have it. Well, it's important to remember that. I mean, this was a war planned in Washington. Yeah, of course. Based on sort of, you know, exaggerated reports and with the pure land grab at its heart for the Black Hills. Custer's plan was to attack and he would have killed a lot of people if he'd won. And we've already talked about Gould, how he has a kind of personal reason to want to get vengeance. And that seems to be why he launches the attack that ends up overwhelming and destroying
他说：“这些白人自找的。他们非要挑起这事，我就成全了他们。”嗯，记住这一点很重要。我是说，这是一场在华盛顿策划的战争。是的，当然。它基于某种夸大的报告，其核心是对黑山（Black Hills）纯粹的土地掠夺。卡斯特的计划是进攻，如果他赢了，他会杀死很多人。我们已经讨论过高尔，他有想要复仇的个人原因。这似乎就是他发动进攻的原因，最终压垮并消灭了
the men on Calhoun Hill. Meanwhile, Custer is up on a further height along the ridge. And you can only imagine what he must have been feeling if he's still alive at this point, watching this horror happen and being absolutely powerless to do anything about it and there are a few men who do manage to get across to him a few but not that many yeah what are we talking about maybe 90 yeah it's kind of by thousands no way they could have broken out at that point and of course it might not have happened like this but lots of accounts think based on the archaeology and based on where the bodies were found, that this is the most plausible. And also people want to believe, everyone wants to believe there was a last stand, don't
卡尔霍恩山上的士兵。与此同时，卡斯特正在山脊更远的高地上。你可以想象，如果他此时还活着，看着这场惨剧发生，却完全无能为力，他心里会作何感想。确实有一些人设法穿插到了他身边，只有几个人，但不是很多。是的，我们说的是多少人？大概90人？在成千上万的人面前，根本没有突围的可能。当然，事情可能不是这样的，但许多根据考古学以及尸体被发现的位置得出的记述认为，这是最合理的情况。而且人们愿意相信，每个人都愿意相信曾有过最后抵抗，
they, Tom? I mean, even we want to believe it. Don't you think? I think that if that's what the archaeology suggests, then, uh, well, because we also know that I think that this is the point where the banners get taken, the boydons, they're called, aren't they? And they're presumably being used to, you know, what is it, coup sticks? Yes, of course.
不是吗，汤姆？我是说，连我们也愿意相信。你不觉得吗？我认为，如果考古学证据表明如此的话，嗯——因为我们也知道，我想正是在这个时候，旗帜被夺走了，也就是所谓的“波伊登旗”（boydons），它们大概被用来，你知道的，做成“击敌棍”（coup sticks）？是的，当然。
I had thought of that. So it's on that, the northern bit of the ridge, that Custer and his men died. It's also at this point that they kill their horses and kind of try to build a wall out of them. Yeah, much as Reno's people had done, you know, hiding behind those putrefying horses on his hill. But they know they've got no hope. Yeah. I mean, they must be outnumbered, what, 20, 30 to one by now? Oh, yeah, at least.
我倒没想到这一点。所以正是在那里，在山脊的北段，卡斯特和他的手下阵亡了。也正是在这个时候，他们杀死了他们的马，并试图用马的尸体筑起一道墙。是的，就像雷诺的手下所做的那样，躲在山上那些正在腐烂的马尸后面。但他们知道自己毫无希望了。是的。我是说，到目前为止，他们在人数上大概处于20比1、30比1的劣势吧？哦，是的，至少。
As we said, Custer probably not identified because his body would surely have been singled out for particular... Well, I mean, interesting, Sitting Bull later gives an interview to a journalist and he says that he watched Custer fell and he said he killed a man when he fell. He laughed. People love this. You see, this is the great. I want that to be true.
正如我们所说，卡斯特可能没有被认出来，因为他的尸体肯定会被挑出来进行特别的……嗯，有趣的是，坐牛（Sitting Bull）后来接受了一位记者的采访，他说他看着卡斯特倒下，并说他在卡斯特倒下时杀了一个人。他笑了。人们很喜欢这个。你看，这才是伟大的。我希望这是真的。
The laughing cavalier. Yes. And all the Norse epic, you know, laughing while I die. That kind of Icelandic or Viking sense of the sort of hero who laughing falls against overwhelming odds. And that was the idea that Custer died with a smile on his face became enormously important to the mystique of The Last Stand. He died with his boots on.
那个大笑的骑士。是的。还有所有的北欧史诗，你知道，在死亡时放声大笑。那种冰岛或维京式的英雄面对压倒性优势时含笑倒下的感觉。这种卡斯特带着微笑死去的想法，对于“最后抵抗”的神秘感变得极其重要。他死时靴子还穿在脚上。
Yeah, exactly. But actually, it's Custer's brother, Tom's fate, that gives you more of a sense of what it was really like. That's hideous. It's not laughing while you die. It's actually dying in horrible agony and then being horrendously mutilated afterwards yeah and do you think that's deliberate do you think they recognized him i can't remember which historian is it might
对，确实如此。但实际上，卡斯特的弟弟汤姆的遭遇，更能让你感受到当时的真实情况。那太可怕了。这不是笑着死去。而是在极度的痛苦中死去，然后死后遭到骇人听闻的肢解。是的。你认为这是故意的吗？你认为他们认出了他吗？我不记得是哪位历史学家了，可能是
be philbrick it might be i don't know one of the many peter cousins one of the many others they say presumably he fought harder than others. And the harder you fought, the more likely you were to have incurred horrific injuries. But certainly it must have been done and dusted by about 5.30. There was a scout called Gerard who was hiding in the woods. And he heard firing continuing until, he said, two hours. And then no more firing. And it's at that point that the women would have come out of the village as was absolutely standard procedure.
菲尔布里克（Philbrick），可能是——我不知道，彼得·库辛斯（Peter Cousins）或者其他许多人中的某一个。他们说，大概是因为他比其他人抵抗得更激烈。你抵抗得越激烈，就越有可能遭受可怕的伤势。但可以肯定的是，到下午5点半左右，战斗已经彻底结束了。有一个名叫热拉尔（Gerard）的侦察兵躲在树林里。他听到枪声一直持续到——他说——两小时。然后就再也没有枪声了。正是在那个时候，村里的女人们会像绝对的标准程序那样走出来。
They would pierce people's ears and things with all they would strip the dead. Well, this says there's a woman, isn't there? Who many years later, who says that they got hold of Custer's corpse and recognized it and did this to his ears and stuck an arrow up his penis yes improbable I think because I think it does seem that they didn't recognize him yeah I don't think they recognized him so are there any survivors I mean there is one famous survivor which is a horse oh yes of course yeah which. Which is Keo's horse, Comanche. Yes. Who, I mean, amazingly does manage to recover and gets tended by the vets. And from that point on, he would walk in processions at the head of Keo's old troop. And as with Kennedy's funeral, where they put the boots on backwards, they do that.
她们会用各种东西刺破人们的耳朵，她们会剥下死者的衣服。嗯，这里说有一个女人，对吧？多年后，她说她们找到了卡斯特的尸体并认出了他，然后对他的耳朵做了这些事，还在他的阴茎里插了一支箭。是的，我觉得不太可能，因为我觉得他们似乎并没有认出他。是的，我觉得他们没有认出他。那么还有幸存者吗？我是说，有一个著名的幸存者，是一匹马。哦，是的，当然。
And Comanche lives to be 29. And apparently you can still see him because they stuffed him. He's on display in the Natural History Museum at the University of Kansas. Crikey. Worth making the trip just for that. Yeah. So taxidermy is something of a theme of this series, unexpectedly. But we love a heroic horse.
那是基奥的马，科曼奇（Comanche）。是的。它竟然奇迹般地康复了，并得到了兽医的照料。从那时起，它会在基奥老部队的前方参加游行队伍。就像肯尼迪的葬礼上把靴子倒着插在马蹬里一样，他们也这么做。科曼奇活到了29岁。显然你现在还能看到它，因为它被做成了标本。它在堪萨斯大学自然历史博物馆展出。天哪。
We do. So maybe good to end on a positive. Yeah. There was one survivor. So Benteen, this is the site that confronts him two days later. As he looks down, he makes that extremely disobliging remark. God damn him or whatever he says about poor old Custer. He'll never fight again.
为了这个都值得去一趟。是的。所以动物剥制标本出乎意料地成了这个系列的一个主题。但我们都喜欢英雄战马。
In total, they had lost 258 men killed and 60 wounded. Lerb Cota and Cheyenne probably lost about 31 warriors, six women, four children. In the grand scheme of things, I suppose you could say it's not the Battle of Kursk or something, but the symbolism could hardly be more powerful. Under Terry, they got back to the river. Terry went back to his steamer and he said to the guy
确实如此。所以也许以积极的结局收尾挺好。是的。还有一个幸存者。所以本廷（Benteine），这就是两天后呈现在他眼前的场景。当他俯视时，他说出了那句极其刻薄的话。不管他对可怜的老卡斯特说了“真他妈的”还是别的什么。他再也不会打仗了。
who commands the steamer. Oh, thank God. White tablecloth. He said to... The flies. They had all the wounded and he said to the guy who commands the steamer. Oh, thank God. White tablecloth. He said to the flies. They had all the wounded. And he said to the guy, the captain, he said, Captain, you have on board the most precious cargo that a boat has ever carried. Every soldier here is suffering with wounds. They are the victims of a terrible blunder, a sad and terrible blunder.
总计，他们有258人阵亡，60人受伤。拉科塔人和夏延人大概损失了31名勇士、6名妇女、4名儿童。从宏观角度来看，我想你可以说这算不上库尔斯克战役之类的，但其象征意义再强烈不过了。在特里（Terry）的带领下，他们回到了河边。特里回到了他的汽船上，他对船长说——
And they rush back east and they break all speed records to get back to the town of Bismarck. And they get back there on the 5th of July. So the day after the nation's 100th birthday. Now, the celebrations of America's centennial had started at kind of just before midnight on the night of the 3rd of July in Philadelphia. The following day, the first story appeared, but not in the East Coast. It was in the West Coast in the Helena Herald of Montana, and that was based on the account of a Crow Scout. But it's not until the 5th of July that the story appears in New York.
噢，谢天谢地。白桌布。他对……那些苍蝇。他们带着所有的伤员，他对那个人——船长说，船长，你船上载着一艘船运送过的最珍贵的货物。这里的每个士兵都在忍受着伤痛。他们是一个可怕的失策的受害者，一个悲惨而可怕的失策。
Basically, when they got back to Bismarck, they told the local newspaperman called Mr. Lounsbury, the story appears in New York. Basically, when they got back to Bismarck, they told the, you know, there's a local newspaperman called Mr. Lounsbury of the Bismarck Tribune, and he found out about it. He dictated the story down the line on the telegram to the New York Herald. It took him, Tom, 22 hours.
他们急速向东赶回，打破了所有速度纪录，回到了俾斯麦镇。他们在7月5日回到了那里。也就是全国独立日100周年的第二天。当时，美国百年庆典的庆祝活动在费城7月3日午夜前不久就开始了。第二天，第一篇报道出现了，但不是在东海岸，而是在西海岸蒙大拿州的《海伦娜先驱报》（Helena Herald），那是基于一个克罗族侦察兵的叙述。但直到7月5日，这篇报道才出现在纽约。
Oh, God. The story, he dictated 40,000 words worth of news. That's supposedly the longest telegram ever sent. I mean, 22 hours. Yeah. And it appeared in the New York Herald on the morning of the 5th. And what about Libby? What about Mrs. Custer?
基本上，当他们回到俾斯麦时，他们把消息告诉了一位名叫劳斯伯里（Lounsbury）的当地报人，他是《俾斯麦论坛报》（Bismarck Tribune）的，他发现了这件事。他通过电报把这个故事一字一句地发给了《纽约先驱报》。汤姆，这花了整整22个小时。
Libby didn't find out from that, of course. She's not in New York. She found out the following day. The news reaches Fort Lincoln, so just across from Bismarck, the commander of the fort went in to see her at seven o'clock in the morning, apparently, and said, you know, we have news. And she could tell straight away. And to her credit, to her immense credit, she insisted on visiting every bereaved widow in the fort to tell them personally what had happened. And she will always tend the flame of her husband's memory from that point on, won't she? So she lived until I think the 1930s.
天哪。这个故事，他口述了长达4万字的新闻。据说是史上发送的最长电报。我是说，22个小时。是的。它出现在5日早上的《纽约先驱报》上。那莉比（Libby）呢？卡斯特夫人呢？
She discovered that Custer had left her enormous debts. She managed to pay them off and she became the guardian of the custer flame she wrote a you know memoirs of him and then she became almost like a sort of this sounds harsh i don't mean it to sound harsh she became professionally custer's widow you know she that was her function her job yeah yeah you know she was very good at it she tended his his image but of course straight away when the news reaches these guys Coast, people are looking, saying, who's to blame? Well, Terry said, you know, the wounded soldiers on board are the victims of a terrible blunder, a sad and terrible blunder. So shades of the charge of the Light Brigade, someone had blundered. Yeah, someone had blundered.
莉比当然不是从那上面知道的。她不在纽约。她是第二天知道这个消息的。消息传到了林肯堡，也就是俾斯麦的对岸，堡垒的指挥官显然在早上七点钟进去见她，说：“你知道的，我们有消息了。”她一下子就看出来了。为了她的名誉，为了她巨大的名誉，她坚持走访堡垒中的每一位丧夫寡妇，亲自告诉她们发生了什么。从那时起，她一生都在守护着她丈夫的记忆之火，不是吗？所以她一直活到大约20世纪30年代。
And so if that is true, so if the disaster is due to a blunder, but of course there is another explanation for it that we'll come to after this, who's blundered. And I suppose there are three figures in the frame. Three figures. General Terry, by the way, you could argue General Terry, who's meant to be the overall commander of the expedition, he doesn't cover himself for glory. Or Crook. Crook. Why didn't he communicate after the Rosebud? So I think that you can point the finger at those two men.
她发现卡斯特给她留下了巨额债务。她设法还清了债务，并成为了“卡斯特之火”的守护者。她写了一本关于他的回忆录，然后她几乎变得像一个——这听起来可能有点刺耳，我不是故意要说得那么刺耳——她成了一名专业的卡斯特遗孀，你知道的，那是她的职能，她的工作。是的，是的，你知道的，她做得很好。她维护了他的形象。当然，当消息传到东海岸时，人们开始寻找原因：到底是谁的错？好吧，特里说，船上的负伤士兵是一个可怕失策的受害者，一个悲惨而可怕的失策。所以这有点像《轻骑兵的冲锋》，有人犯了错。是的，有人犯了错。
Accepting that, on the day itself, mistakes were made, I think it's fair to the finger at those two men, you know, accepting that on the day itself. Mistakes were made, I think it's fair to say, Tom, isn't it? So let's start with the obvious candidate. He's the only person into whom there was an investigation. And that is Major Reno. Reno had a terrible life afterwards. He was court-martialed for sexual assault. He kept kind of wandering around, peering into women's,
所以如果这是真的，如果这场灾难是由一个失策造成的——当然，我们稍后会讲到对它的另一种解释——到底是谁犯了错？我想画面中出现了三个人物。三个人物。特里将军，顺便说一句，你可以认为特里将军作为远征的总指挥，并没有为自己赢得什么荣耀。或者克鲁克。克鲁克。为什么他在罗斯巴德（Rosebud）战役后不进行通信？所以我觉得你可以把矛头指向这两个人。
the windows of the women's quarters in forts. He behaves extremely badly, generally. He's always getting drunk and getting into fights. He's a very troubled man. So Frederick Whittaker, who you began with, the poem, Custer's first biographer, the man who really invents the last stand story. Whittaker basically waged an endless campaign against Reno and said Reno was responsible for Custer's death. And lots of people, when they were writing accounts in the 20s and 30s,
承认在当天的确犯了错误，我觉得把矛头指向这两个人是公平的，汤姆，不是吗？所以让我们从最明显的人选开始。他是唯一一个接受过调查的人。那就是雷诺少校。雷诺后来的生活糟透了。他因性侵犯而被军事法庭审判。他总是到处游荡，窥探堡垒里女眷住所的窗户。他总体的行为极其恶劣。他总是喝醉酒并惹是生非。他是一个非常麻烦的人。所以你一开始提到的那首诗的作者弗雷德里克·惠特克（Frederick Whittaker），卡斯特的第一位传记作家，也就是真正发明了“最后抵抗”故事的人。惠特克基本上对雷诺展开了无休止的攻击，并声称雷诺对卡斯特的死负有责任。许多人在20年代和30年代撰写记述时，
this one here I found, Robert G. Carter, I think it's in the 1920s, Reno showed the white feather from the start and his entire conduct was that of a white-livered yellow street coward. If there was ever a pusillanimous poltroon in the army whose name should be handed down to future generations as an arrant coward, Marcus A. Reno is the man. I mean, I think that actually there is a measure of truth to that. If that Lakota woman who we quoted in the previous episode was accurate in saying that had Reno charged as Custer would undoubtedly have charged right at the beginning, then perhaps things might've been different. I think that was the only prospect
比如我在这里找到的这本，罗伯特·G·卡特（Robert G. Carter），我想大约是在20世纪20年代写的：“雷诺从一开始就表现得像个懦夫，他的一言一行完全就是一个胆小如鼠、脸色发青的黄色街头懦夫。如果军队里曾经有过一个胆怯的懦夫，他的名字应该作为彻底的懦夫流传后世，那个人就是马库斯·A·雷诺。”我是说，我觉得这其实有几分道理。如果我们在上一集里引用的那个拉科塔女人说的准确的话——如果雷诺像卡斯特一开始无疑会做的那样发起冲锋，那么事情可能会有所不同。我认为那是他们赢得这场战役的唯一希望。
they had of winning the battle. So it is possible that Reno was the only person who had the opportunity to seize a victory in his hands and he fluffed it. Yeah. He did fluff it and he didn't command well. There's parts of me that feel sorry for Reno. Yeah. I feel sorry for him. He's a very troubled man. Yeah. But I do think that he was the only person who could have won that battle. But he's not a Custer. No. Had Custer been there, he might have won it. He's the wrong man in the wrong place.
所以雷诺很有可能是唯一一个有机会将胜利抓在手中却搞砸了的人。是的。他的确搞砸了，而且指挥得并不好。有时我甚至会同情雷诺。是的。我同情他。他是个非常麻烦的人。是的。但我确实认为他是唯一一个本可能赢得那场战役的人。但他不是卡斯特。不。如果卡斯特在那里，他可能会赢。他是错的时间出现在错地点的错误人选。
He behaves very badly. But whose task was it to assign him that job? It was Custer's. So ultimately, if we are spreading blame around, the blame is with Custer. Historians generally, I would say, treat Reno... They agree that Reno was a coward and that he panicked. I think most of us are perhaps less inclined to be too judgmental because we know we've never been in a battle ourselves and we don't know how we would react.
他的行为非常恶劣。但分配给他这项任务是谁的责任？是卡斯特的。所以归根结底，如果我们要在各方之间分摊责任，责任在卡斯特。我可以说，历史学家们普遍对雷诺持这种态度……他们一致认为雷诺是个懦夫，他恐慌了。我想我们大多数人可能不太愿意过分评判，因为我们知道我们自己从未上过战场，也不知道自己会有什么反应。
I know exactly how I'd react. Well, anybody who's ever read about the men in the World Wars knows that every man is only brave up until the point when he cracks i mean everybody cracks you know it's very rare for somebody not to there's always a point you never know when it will be so that point where you know bloody knife's head explodes in his face can i blame him for panicking at that point and now of course lots of people who will listen to this and say god you're making excuses somebody who. And now, of course, lots of people who will listen to this and say, God, you're making excuses to somebody who is in a position of responsibility. But there's part of me that does feel a little bit sorry for him. Now, Benteen, on the other hand,
我完全知道自己会有什么反应。好吧，任何读过关于世界大战中士兵书籍的人都知道，每个人都只在崩溃之前勇敢，我是说每个人都会崩溃，你知道的，极少有人不会崩溃。总会有一个临界点，你永远不知道它何时会到来。所以，当血刀（Bloody Knife）的头颅在他面前炸开时，我能怪他在那个时刻恐慌吗？现在，当然，许多听到这话的人会说：“天哪，你是在为一个处于责任位置的人找借口。”但有时我确实对他感到有点同情。现在，另一方面，本廷，
Benteen did behave very well in the later stages of the battle. He rallies the men on the hill. But historians tend to be very critical of Benteen, don't they? I think harshly. Do you? I think he behaves well. I think that perhaps his prevarications over... Prevarications that people point to over what he thought about custer i mean it's possible that he thought i mean either custer is dead or he's winning a glorious victory yeah and either way there's no point in going to it's his job to go tom i mean i understand that had he gone up he
本廷在战役的后期阶段确实表现得非常好。他在山上重新集结了部队。但历史学家往往对本廷持严厉批评态度，不是吗？我觉得未免太苛刻了。是吗？我觉得他表现得很好。我认为，也许人们指出的他那些推诿……关于他对卡斯特看法的推诿，我是说，他可能觉得——要么卡斯特已经死了，要么他正在取得辉煌的胜利。是的，无论哪种情况，去……都是他的责任，汤姆。我是说我理解，如果他赶上去的话，
would have been wiped out as well and reno's men would have been wiped out so bentin is the man who saves yeah you know a fair proportion of the seventh cavalry and i think he deserves credit for it thank you so much i hope you remember that next time you confront a similarly outwardly amiable but ultimately malign personality dominic that's i see the inner good in you oh that's nice and that i think is one of the lessons lessons of studying the Little Bighorn campaign. So we're glad you've got something positive out of it. So finally, of course, Custer. Now, interestingly, at first, the reaction was mixed to Custer. He wasn't immediately the national hero.
他也会被全歼，雷诺的手下也会被全歼。所以本廷才是那个拯救了——你知道的，相当大比例的第七骑兵队的人，我认为他理应获得赞誉。非常感谢你，多米尼克，我希望下次你面对一个表面上看似随和但本质上恶毒的人时能记住这一点。我看得到你内心的善良。哦，这太好了。我想这也是研究小大角战役的教训之一。所以我们很高兴你从中获得了一些积极的收获。那么最后，当然是卡斯特。有趣的是，起初人们对卡斯特的反应是复杂的。他并没有立刻成为民族英雄。
So Republican newspapers, because, of course, they remember that he has attacked Grant and he's been endorsing Democratic presidential candidates and all kinds of things. Republican newspapers said, what a fool Custer is. Disobedience of orders, a fatal blunder, says the headline in the Chicago Daily News. And it's Democrat papers that say, what a brilliant person Custer is. A friend to the white man, an enemy to, you know, everybody else, terribly hard done by the battle, little big horn and so on. Actually, over time, that partisan animosity just disappears, doesn't it?
所以共和党报纸——因为，当然，他们记得他曾攻击过格兰特，他还一直在支持民主党总统候选人以及诸如此类的事情——共和党报纸说：“卡斯特真是个傻瓜。违抗命令，致命的失策，”《芝加哥每日新闻》（Chicago Daily News）的头条这样写道。而民主党报纸则说：“卡斯特是多么杰出的人啊。白人的朋友，所有其他人的敌人，在小大角战役中受到了极大的不公待遇，诸如此类。”随着时间的推移，这种党派敌意其实就渐渐消失了，不是吗？
And everybody concludes, oh, Custer is brilliant. He's such a martyr and a hero of the West. Actually, I'll tell you the single, the saddest sentence in this whole story. And it comes from not a brilliant man to be honest it's custer's father who's still alive emmanuel custer and when he read the papers saying that it was custer's mistake and that had led all these men to their deaths he said they wrong my dead boy there's something about those words you know they wrong my dead boy that kind of really resonates with me. I don't know why.
每个人都断言，哦，卡斯特太棒了。他是西部的烈士和英雄。实际上，我来告诉你整个故事中最令人悲伤的一句话。它不是出自一个天才之口，老实说，那是卡斯特的父亲，当时还健在的伊曼纽尔·卡斯特（Emmanuel Custer）。当他读到报纸上说那是卡斯特的错误，导致所有人丧命时，他说：“他们污蔑了我死去的儿子。”那句话里有些东西——你知道的，“他们污蔑了我死去的儿子”——真的引起了我的共鸣。我不知道为什么。
Well, because you're massively sentimental. Yeah, because ultimately a very kindly person. Despite, beneath your malign, cynical, evil exterior. Yeah, clearly. There's a gooey centre of sentimentality. Definitely. I've got a Disney core. That's why.
好吧，因为你极其多愁善感。是的，因为归根结底，你是一个非常善良的人。尽管在你的恶毒、犬儒、邪恶的外表之下。对，显然。你有一颗迪士尼式的内心。这就是原因。
Now, you're generally more critical of Custer than me, aren't you, Tom? Do they wrong his dead boy? Is Custer at fault? Yeah, I think absolutely. He didn't reconnoiter. He had lots of people telling him, he was arrogant. He was complacent. He divided his troops up. Yeah, but that was undoubtedly a mistake. He sent Reno, whose belly was too yellow to cope with the stress of it. I see why he does it. His dash, his self-confidence has taken him to incredible heights of achievement.
现在，你对卡斯特的批判通常比我更严厉，对吧，汤姆？他们真的污蔑了他死去的儿子吗？是卡斯特的错吗？是的，绝对是。他没有侦察。有很多人提醒过他，他太傲慢了。他自满。他分散了部队。是的，但这无疑是个错误。他派出了雷诺，后者的胆子太小，无法应对这种压力。我理解他为什么要这么做。他的冲劲、他的自信将他带到了令人难以置信的成就高度。
But you only have to be unlucky once. It's not just bad luck. It's bad judgment as well at this point, I think. Well, that's the nature with any swashbuckling commander, isn't it? So more conservative commanders are never in that position. They're safety first. On the other hand, they don't win smashing unexpected victories.
但你只需要有一次运气不好就行了。我认为这不仅是运气不好，此时此刻这也是判断失误。好吧，这就是任何鲁莽指挥官的特质，不是吗？所以那些更保守的指挥官绝不会陷入这种境地。他们将安全放在第一位。另一方面，他们也赢不了那种石破天惊、出人意料的伟大胜利。
I completely accept that. And I also accept that the nature of Custer's generalship, the nature of his dash, his celerity, his swagger, his charisma,
我完全接受这一点。我也接受卡斯特的指挥风格的本质——他的冲劲、他的敏捷、他的傲慢、他的个人魅力——
is why we're sitting here talking about him and not talking about all the other generals on the planes who lost men and ended up dead. Yeah, we're not doing a podcast. We're not talking about Fetterman. No the planes who lost men and ended up dead. Yeah. We're not doing a podcast. We're not talking about Fetterman.
正是我们今天坐在这里谈论他，而不是谈论平原上所有其他那些失去手下并最终丧命的将军的原因。是的，我们没在做播客。我们没在谈论费特曼。不，费特曼，正是如此。就卡斯特而言，事实上，他的传记作家们的趋势，我认为在最近一段时间——从，比方说，《兵临城下》或者《埋我心于伤膝谷》开始，确实出现了一种反对卡斯特的转向。
No, Fetterman, exactly. Just on Custer, actually the trend among his biographers, I think, very recently. So there was definitely a turn against Custer, let's say from the, you know, bury my heart at wounded knee. Yeah. So the 60s, I mean, Custer is not a 1960s person and the kind of the influence of Vietnam. 60s, 70s, 80s, the trend is to be down on Custer is not a 1960s person. And the influence of Vietnam... 60s, 70s, 80s, the trend is to be down on Custer, to say a reckless, arrogant, racist commander. But actually, in recent years, there's been a slight swing of the pendulum back.
所以从60年代开始，我是说，卡斯特可不是一个60年代那样的人，还有越南战争的影响。60年代、70年代、80年代，这种趋势是贬低卡斯特，说他是一个鲁莽、傲慢、种族主义的指挥官。但实际上，近年来，这种潮流又稍微摆动回去了。
And I think quite a lot of historians say, listen, it takes two sides to win a battle. And actually, the story of the Little Bighorn is not the Americans lost it by their mistakes. Right. So it's not the blunder. It's the success. Exactly. And the success belongs, I think, preeminently to Sitting Bull, but I think particularly
我想很多历史学家会说，听着，要赢得一场战役需要双方的努力。实际上，小大角的历史并非美国人因自身错误而惨败。对。所以这不是一个失策的问题，而是成功的问题。没错。而这种成功，我认为主要属于坐牛，但特别属于
Crazy Horse. Yeah. It's Sitting Bull who unites disparate groups into the biggest encampment ever. And he is confident this will protect us. And he's right. It does. If he hadn't done that. I agree.
疯马。是的。是坐牛将不同的部落联合成有史以来最大的营地。他坚信这会保护他们。他是对的。确实如此。如果他没有那样做的话——我同意。
If he hadn't been so successful and skillful in doing that, he'd have been toast. But I also think that it is Crazy Horse's leadership on the battlefield and the rosebud, which is an absolutely crucial overture. But it also gives the warriors the confidence to know that they can take on American soldiers and beat them. I mean, it does seem that in both cases, when they attack Reno, it's the idea that Crazy
如果他在那件事上没有表现得那么成功和熟练，他早就玩完了。但我也认为，疯马在战场上的领导力以及罗斯巴德战役，绝对是一个至关重要的序幕。它也赋予了勇士们信心，让他们知道自己能够与美洲士兵较量并击败他们。我的意思是，在两种情况下，当他们攻击雷诺时，似乎都是因为疯马要来的信念；而在对山脊上卡斯特手下的进攻中，正是疯马的存在激发了他们的彻底歼灭。是的。所以绝对的人数优势。这是美国人从未预料到的唯一一件事，尽管侦察兵已经说过人数非常多。
Horse is coming. And then with the attack on Custer's men on the ridge, it's Crazy Horse's presence that inspires their destruction. Yeah. So sheer numbers. That's the one thing that none of the Americans ever anticipated, even when the scouts said it's very big. You know, when General Sherman was told about the defeat, he said he couldn't believe it. And he said, I did not think there were enough Indians there to do it. Right. And the fact that they are there and they're coherent and they're willing to follow something that approximates to orders.
你知道的，当谢尔曼将军（General Sherman）听到战败消息时，他说他简直不敢相信。他说：“我没想到那里有足够多的印第安人能做到这一点。”对。他们确实在那里，而且他们很有条理，愿意服从某种接近命令的指挥。
I mean, it's not orders. It's the inspiration of a very, very charismatic war leader. But I think that is down to Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse and the courage of the men who fought with them. Just on the Lakota, of course, the great irony is all the talk about the last stand. This is their last stand, actually, isn't it? I mean, because their greatest victory.
我是说，这并非严格意义上的军令。这是受一位极其具有个人魅力的战地领袖的感召。但我认为这要归功于坐牛和疯马，以及与他们并肩作战的勇士们的勇气。就拉科塔人而言，最大的讽刺莫过于所有关于“最后抵抗”的谈论。实际上，这才是他们自己的最后抵抗，不是吗？因为这是他们最伟大的胜利。
This makes it inevitable. There's no way after this that the United States federal government and the US Army will just say, as they did after the Fetterman massacre, that they'll just say, okay, fine, you win. We'll stay out of the Black Hills. The scale of the humiliation on the nation's birthday is such, it makes it absolutely inevitable that they will come back for more in a way that will make it absolutely impossible for the Lakota to win out or to survive with the lifestyle. Well, I mean, that world was dying anyway, wasn't it? The world of the bison and roaming across the plains. And
这使得局势不可避免。在此之后，美国联邦政府和美国陆军绝不可能像在费特曼屠杀事件后那样，轻描淡写地表示“好吧，算你们赢，我们不会涉足黑山”。在国庆日发生如此规模的羞辱，绝对不可避免地会促使他们卷土重来，而这将使得拉科塔人彻底无法获胜，也无法以原有的生活方式生存下去。不过话说回来，那种世界无论如何也终究是要消亡的，不是吗？野牛成群、纵横驰骋于大平原的世界，以及
just on Custer, Tom, now we will tell the story of Crazy Horse and Sitting Bull and the Lakota, but just on Custer, you love the subject of Custer, don't you? But now that we've finished this whole story of his part in the story, do you feel as favorably inclined to him as you did when you and I were young and we were reading that Lady Bird book? Well, so I didn't know all the role that he plays in the racial politics that follows the end of the Civil War. I didn't know that. And of course, there's a world of difference between a children's book describing tales of heroism and daring do and then watching say little big man which i remember watching at quite an impressionable age dustin hoffman yeah dustin hoffman and in which the washita is cast as a massacre from vietnam the milai massacre or something i was very into bury my heart a wounded knee i was very into
关于卡斯特，汤姆，我们接下来将讲述疯马、坐牛以及拉科塔人的故事。但仅就卡斯特而言，你不是很喜欢卡斯特这个研究主题吗？不过，在我们讲完了他在这段历史中所扮演角色的整个故事之后，你对他的好感是否还像你我年轻时读那本“瓢虫书”时那样呢？嗯，我当时并不知道他在美国内战结束后的种族政治中所扮演的全部角色，我对此一无所知。当然，儿童读物中那些充满英雄主义和惊险刺激的故事，与观看电影（比如《小巨人》）之间有着天壤之别。我记得看这部电影时正处于懂事的年纪，主演是达斯汀·霍夫曼，对，达斯汀·霍夫曼。在这部电影中，沃希托河战役被描绘成了一场类似于越南战争中美莱村屠杀那样的屠杀。我当时非常痴迷于《魂断于此》，我非常
sacred spirit all that kind of thing i was very open to seeing the 7th Cavalry as an exterminatory force, very kind of down on them. But having said all that, there is something almost joyous about Custer's zest for battle and for living that I think is appealing and does explain why he is so vivid as a historical figure in a way that all these other kind of almost identikit generals with their mutton chops and their whiskers and their, you know, their kind of doer behaviour just doesn't. I mean, he does dazzle and this is why we've done this great series on him. He's like one of those characters, isn't he? Like, I mean, we've done some pretty terrible, you know, by many standards, Hernán Cortés.
喜欢《神圣之灵》这类作品，我也非常乐意将第七骑兵队视为一支灭绝性质的军队，对他们颇有微词。但话虽如此，卡斯特对战斗和生活的热情中有一种近乎狂喜的特质，我认为这很有吸引力，也确实解释了为什么他作为一个历史人物会如此鲜活。相比之下，其他那些几乎千篇一律的将军们，留着络腮胡和髭须，行为举止一板一眼，却完全没有这种魅力。我的意思是，他的确光芒四射，这也是我们为他制作这个宏大系列节目的原因。他就像那种特定的人物，不是吗？就好比——我们其实也讲述过一些在许多标准下都相当可怕的人物，比如埃尔南·科尔特斯。
I don't think he's like Hernán Cortés. Well, Hernán Cortés is much more calculating. I think the person he reminds me of is Rupert of the Rhine, who likewise was a kind of youthful hero, the dashing cavalier who charges down hills and is swashbuckling. But of course, who stages all kinds of massacres and who ends up a slaver in the caribbean and seems to you know i mean essentially not the stuff of a hero and yet he is heroic he does have the kind of the dash he does have the swagger the archetype of that is alexander the great leading charges swashbuckling blonde hair blowing in the breeze yeah i think i mean alexander is a
我不觉得他像埃尔南·科尔特斯。嗯，埃尔南·科尔特斯要精于算计得多。我认为他让我想起的人是莱茵的鲁珀特，那同样是一位带有青春气息的英雄，是个冲下山坡、飞扬跋扈、充满浪漫色彩的骑士。当然，他后来策划了各种大屠杀，最终沦为加勒比海地区的奴隶贩子，看起来——我的意思是，本质上这并不是一个英雄的材料，然而他确实很英雄，他确实有一种冲劲，也确实有一种狂妄自大的气质。这种原型的代表人物就是亚历山大大帝，率领冲锋，意气风发，金色的头发在微风中飘扬。是的，我认为亚历山大是一个
vastly more significant figure vastly more resonant figure. I think, I mean, fundamentally, Custer is a slight figure in the kind of the scales of history. But the reason for studying him and the reason that I, the justification for doing this series in the depth that we have done is that he is a brilliant, brilliant way of looking at this period of American history that is so important. And yet, relative to other periods of American history, it's very little studied. And Custer is the great kind of shining figure from this period, as also, I think, are Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse in very different ways. And it's the fact that it's the fusion it's the way that these two unbelievably dynamic figures end up meeting the symmetry of the story is perfect and there are certain episodes certain narratives in history that do have a quality of symmetry that just makes them yeah kind of perfect for study we were talking about the homeric quality of it weren't we the fact that it feel and the fact that it feels like it could be a viking epic or whatever so we will as we said
意义远为重大的人物，其影响力也深远得多。我认为，从根本上讲，在历史的天平上，卡斯特是一个无足轻重的人物。但研究他的理由，以及我——我们以目前的深度制作这个系列的合理性在于，他是审视这一段极为重要的美国历史的一个极其精彩的切入点。然而，与美国历史的其他时期相比，这段时期受到的研究却非常少。卡斯特正是这一时期最耀眼的标志性人物，当然，以截然不同的方式来看，坐牛和疯马也是如此。正是因为这种融合——这两个不可思议地充满活力的人物最终相遇的方式——故事的对称性堪称完美。历史上有某些事件、某些叙事确实具有一种对称之美，这使得它们——是的——简直是研究的绝佳素材。我们之前谈论过它的荷马史诗般的特质，不是吗？那种感觉，以及它感觉起来就像是一部维京史诗或诸如此类的东西。所以，正如我们所说
end the stories of we'll tell you what happened to crazy horse and sitting bull and indeed the lakota more generally and that story does end with a another really extraordinary and very very moving set piece which is the story of the ghost dance and then the massacre at Wounded Knee. And we will be telling that story next time, won't we? So come back next time for the end of this epic adventure. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
我们将收尾这些故事，告诉大家疯马和坐牛究竟遭遇了什么，以及拉科塔人更广泛的结局。这个故事确实以另一个真正非凡且极为感人的重头戏收尾，那就是“幽灵舞”的故事，随后便是伤膝河大屠杀。我们将在下期节目中讲述这个故事，对吧？所以请下期继续收听，来收看这场史诗般冒险的结局。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即全部》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦以及问答环节的固定去处
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
我们将在节目中带大家一探娱乐业的内幕，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场活动门票的特权
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。